Слава Україні
Слава знову літо знову спека знову
зазхання на мову знову ми з вами під
стінами парламенту але вже не 2012 рік
Так ми з вами вже не котята яких можна
розводити так Так ми не дозволимо
зазіхання на мову тому що після
2019 2012 року був Майдан 1314
була війна Яка почалася в 14му році була
війна в якій Російська Федерація
використовує язик як зброю проти мови як
зброя проти українців ми стали
сильнішими ми ті які призвели до того що
рік тому було вступив в дію закон про
мову про функціонування української мови
як державної
цей закон Ми теж проштовхували і там в
стінах парламенту І тут на вулиці і
зараз ми не дамо скасувати цей закон
який є одним із найважливіших наших
здобутків за останніх пть років Ми
зупинимо будь-які спроби реваншу Ми
зупинимо будь-які спроби
русифікації нам говорять що можливо цей
закон сьогодні не буде розглядатися
попри те що в понеділок було заявлено що
саме 16 липня саме в день
ритиліття декларації про суверенітет
хочуть розглядати закон який повертає
русифікацію в українські школи дуже
лічно адже Мова - це один з базисів
українського суверенітету вчора заявили
що сьогодній вже немає в порядку денному
Якщо так це добре це Одна з наших
перемог Але ми не віримо знаєте в мене
дуже багато було знайомих політв'язнів
які казали що коли спілкуєшся з гбнею не
плач не бійся не проси таке саме
ставлення наше до цієї влади
так Через це ми залишаємося сьогодні тут
на випадок якщо в когось засрблять руки
проголосити чергову позачергову сесію
для того щоб ухвалити цей закон Через це
ми зберемося завтра тут Тому що завтра
нібито цей закон буде ухвалюватися ми як
депутати Будемо робити все від нас
залежне для того щоб він не розладався в
цьому залі але нам потрібна ваша
допомога Нам потрібні тисячі людей тут в
Києві на вулицях Нам потрібні тисячі
людей на вулицях всіх українських місць
для того щоб ця Влада зрозуміла не
лізьте до мови не лізьте до мови не
рухайте мови інакше не буде вам не буде
спокою і Я переконаний що ми сьогодні
проведемо чудовий день захищаючи мову
чудовий день вітаючи один одного з
трицятиліттям суверенітету надзвичайно
важливою подією яка стала важливим
кроком до Незалежності України і так
само ми проведемо чудовий день завтра
будемо готові сьогодні будемо готові
завтра Я переконаний що ми відстоїмо Я
переконаний що ми переможемо Я
переконаний що нам не буде соромно перед
своїми нащадками що ми не зуміли
відстоювати тих великих здобутків які
отримали за останніх пть років разом
сила Слава Україні разом сила разом сила
разом сила разом сила разом сила разом
сила разом сила слово чому ти не твердиє
критьсяя Що серед бою Так ясно І
скритьсяя чому ти не гострий безжалісний
меч той що здіймав ражі голови з плеч ти
моя щира гартована мова я тебе видобить
спіхви готова Тільки ж ти кров з мого
серця пролєш вражого ж серця клинком не
проб'єш вигострі виточу зброю Із кристу
скільки достане снаги меній хисту потім
почеплю її при стіні іншим На втіху На
втіху мені слово моя єдиная зброя Ми не
повинні загинуть обоє Месники дужі
приймуть мою зброю кинуться з нею
відважно до бою І скажемо так заважає
мова геть доростова заважає мова геть до
Ростова заважає мова геть тороскова
заважає мова геть тороскова заважає мова
геньроважа мова
геньрова Що ж і я маю велику приємність
заповісти що на цю сцену зараз вийде
людина для якого Мова - це не просто
серце і душа а це просто сутність людина
завдяки
кому вдалося зібрати усі голоси і
прийняти закон про українську мову
Андрій
Парубій
Слава Україні
роям Слава Слава Україні Героям слава
Слава Україні Героям слава друзі я
пригадую день прийняття закону про мову
трошки більше років року тому коли ми
зібдалися тут на цьому майдані і я
пригадую скільки було усміхниго
А скільки людей особливо старших
політв'язнів просто плакали від щастя що
нарешті Україна має повноцінний закон
про мову нам говорили про те що буде
розкол в суспільстві що будуть сварки А
я хочу
зазначити жодних сварок не було
прийняття законом про мову було
підтримано у всіх куточках України тому
що Українська мова єднає мова єднає так
мова єднає мова єднає мова єднає мова
єднає мова єднає мова єднає і ви знаєте
коли ми приймали закон про квоти
української мови на радіо на телебаченні
ми побачили небувалий розвиток
української пісні українські пісні Стали
світовими хітами україн
фільми стали унікальним явищем сучасної
української історії а закон про мову
остаточно закріпив цей наш розвиток
української мови але чи могли ми тоді
уявити що мене всього трошки більше року
і нам доведеться збиратися тут щоб
захищати українську мову Коли ми йшли на
вибори Ми попереджали
що ці так звані
нові обличчя будуть робити ревізію і
віри і армії і мови нам дехто говорив Та
ж Подивіться це ж нові люди це ж Вітер
змін А я тоді сказав Якщо це Вітер змін
Чому від нього так смердить русским
духом І сьогодні ми
бачимо яка їхня насправді ціль ми Їх
попереджали Не чіпайте мо Я їм говорив
Не чіпайте мову бо земля під вами буде
горіти але в цей понеділок голова партії
слуга
народу вимагає поставити закон
пужанського по знищенню української мови
А разумков голова Верховної Ради каже
Так так так четвер ми його обов'язково
розглянемо вдуматись 16 липня на 30ту
річницю проголошення Декларації про
державний
суверенітет декларації в якій було чітко
сказано що українська держава має
обов'язок розвитку української мови
функціонування української мови у всіх
сферах суспільного життя бо батьки
засновники і ті хто творили декларацію
розуміли що Мова - це питання не тільки
гуманітарне Мова це питання не тільки
спілкування Мова - це також питання
безпеки і існування українсь
нації бо де є українська мова там є
Україна де нема української мови Там ми
бачимо наступ російських окупантів ми
бачимо вбивство наших воїнів на
передовій кілька днів тому ми ховали на
Майдані героя України Тараса матвієва і
в мене ще один спогад 8 років тому ми з
ним разом нушували біля Українського
дому на мовному Майдані пригадуєте Тут є
багато тих Я бачив які були на мовному
Майдані тоді я робив все можливе щоб не
допустити закону зніченка Ківалова в
залі а потім ми протестували біля
Українського дому і Зеленський сьогодні
йде шляхом
Януковича так на біля Українського дому
ми не змогли перемогти але вже за
півтора року Янукович втікав від
українського народу в Ростов і
Зеленський має розуміти такий самий
напрям і для нього якщо він буде чіпати
українську мову так
Так бо для нас питання української мови
Це питання життя держави це питання
майбутнього Української держави і тому
сьогодні ми говоримо Мова - це зброя
тому сьогодні я їм ще раз Хочу повторити
не чіпай
українську мову посієте Московський
вітер пожнете українську бурю мова
єднає мова єднає мова єднає мова єднає
мова єднає мова єднає мова єднає мова
єднає Ми будемо тут і не допустимо
прийняття цього закону ми будемо в залі
Я обіцяю вам від себе від всіх депутатів
не допустити прийняття цього закону але
ми маємо бути як на Майдані разом плече
до плеча всі українські сили сьогодні
повинні їм показати ми не допустимо
скасування закону про українську мову і
я знаю ми переможемо з нами Бог і з нами
Україна Слава Україні
Слава Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
Україні Героям слава
як довго ждали ми своєї волі слова і ось
вона співа бринить бринить Співає наша
мова чарує тішить і п'янить як довго
ждали ми
уклінчолом народу що рідну мову нам
зберіг зберіг таку страшну негоду коли ж
і сам
стоять не
міг я думаю цей дим який зараз з'явився
напевно присвячеки Андрію володимировичу
паробію відомий борець зокрема в стінах
парламенту Дякуємо
Андрію Наша команда європейської
солідарності прошу
привітати запрошую до слова Ірину
Геращенко яка тоді в 2019 році коли
ухвалювався цей закон а також дуже
багато важли
базових законів для української
ідентичності була віце-спікером зараз
вона співголова нашої фракції Ірино
прошу Дякую дорогі друзі європейська
Солідарність вся наша фракція в якій
представлені депутати з різних куточків
України Ми пам'ятаємо що регіони в
України не 25 якто сказав неоч
Зеленський Ми дякуємо кожному з вас від
Львівщини до Харківщини від Луганська до
Черкас від Полтави до Київщини які
сьогодні зібрались на цьому Майдані
друзі для нас армія мова Віра - Це не
гасла це фундамент української держави і
ми пишаємося тим що це були не наші
передвиборчі гасла як намагаються
сказати слуги це був наш звіт за те що
вдалося зробити цій команді разом з
Петром Порошенком в
2014-19 коли разом з вами з волонтерами
з українською громадою з ветеранами ми
відродили українську армію і крок за
кроком звільняли українську землю коли
разом з вами ми змогли захистити
українську мову коли разом з вами ми
сказали ні рускому миру в тому числі в
питанні віри я сама з Черкас і
народилася в двомовній родині як дуже
багато в той час українці я навчалася в
російській школі і от перше таке
усвідомлення мого українства було в
моєму селі в бабу дідусі на Черкащині
потім в університеті і я пишаюся тим що
зараз в нашій фракції ще двоє людей з
якими ми разом навчались в університеті
це володимир арієв і Микола Княжицький і
вони не давали Мені там сказати Жодного
слова російською просто не відповідали
коли я йому казала Здравствуйте грещенко
Добрий день тому Дякую і цим хлопцям
одним з найкращих вчителів для всієї
країни української був Український
президент Віктор Ющенко який дуже багато
зробив для української мови Я пишаюся що
в нашій команді сьогодні так багато
людей з якими ми тоді працювали разом
для того щоб Україна відчула себе
Україною щоби тут був фундамент але
найбільше мабуть для цього зробив кожен
з вас хто сьогодні усвідомлює як важлива
мова і наша команда спікер Андрій
паробій і президент Порошенко цей закон
підписав Президент Порошенко вже після
насправді виборів для того щоби Показати
що ми поставимо червоні рубежі кожному
хто сміє переступити в питаннях армії
мови і віри і знаєте що я вам скажу про
нашу команду Петро порошенко- Поліглот
він знає кілька європейських мов Льоша
ганчеренка коли він говорить в Франції
чи в Британії французького чи
англійського його Там приймають за носія
мови друзі А я хочу сказати що я
викликаю пана божанськова на дуель
написати диктант російською мовою Він її
не знає друзі і я запевняю вас що він
неуч він не знає російської мови він і
суржика не знає для них це політиканство
це мічена червона Кремлівська карта Щоб
дістати її перед виборами кинути і
тріпихати суспільство ми за те щоб кожен
українець знав англійську німецьку
французьку кримськотатарську ми
пишаємося Що в нашій команді є Мустафа
джемірів і ахтем чийгос і ви знаєте що
Артем чийго щодня після парламента йде
до своєї вчительки вчити українську тому
що в нашій команді є чийгод і немає
азірових які за 60 років не змогли
вивчити української Ми хочемо подякувати
кожному послу європейської країни які
приїжджали сюди і вчили українську і
зараз От наприклад закінчилась каденція
тут посла Норвегії в Україні друзі Він
знає українську краще ніж бужанський ну
Як таке може бути друзі але але от оці
слуги і бужанські вони не знають і
російської це неочі не оки бужанський ми
з тобою напишемо диктант російською і
українською і я вважаю що я напишу в
тися раз краще ці два диктанти і вся
наша команда тому що питання не в мові
ніхто не забороняє в нашій країні і
російську але державна має бути тільки
українська і кожна українська Дитина
кожен школяр має мати рівні права
вивчити українську щоб вступити в
найкращий українські університети щоби
потім мати право бути найкращими
держслужбовцями не сегрегуйте
українських дітей ні в Дніпрі ні в
Харкові ніде українські діти мають знати
українську мову а українським дорослим
соромно її не знати тому і Рабінович
буде говорити в цій залі українською і
весь опозиційний блок там Як він
називається А хто не знає української
будь ласка чемодан вокзал Росія друзі і
ми сьогодні сильні наша команда
політичної європейської солідарності
тільки тому що з нами є наш лідер Петро
Порошенко і з нами є український народ з
нами є всі Ви сьогодні дуже важкий день
Сьогодні буде голосування про закон про
вибори яким вони так само хочуть знаєте
закласти фундамент для фальсифікацій не
дамо Дякуємо нашому Руслану кназевичу
Дякуємо Максу саврасову які стоять на
поправках сьогодні вони знову вносять
закон про райони якім без консультацій з
місцевими громадами гаються деякі райони
знищити а деякі райони укрупнити І не
дати їм ніяких повноважень не дамо
сьогодні Вони намагаються в кінці дня
поставити постанову про невизнання
світам референдуму якого Кремль провів в
окупованому Криму Ми нагадаємо сьогодні
зеленському що ні другая сторона воює на
Донбасі Що це Росія а не другая сторона
і вся наша команда сьогодні друзі буде
виходити до вас спілкуватися передавати
новини здали для того щоб разом ми
показали що не дамо жодного шансу
наступу на українську мову Разом і до
кінця Разом і до кінця Разом і до кінця
Разом і до кінця Разом і до кінця Разом
і до кінця а ви знаєте на Майдані як Ми
стояли То ми сказали так що До кінця
ворогів а з нашого боку разом і до
перемоги Так що хай вороги кінча
і то швидіше і ногами вперед а ми будемо
українці в Україні перемагати заради
всіх громадян Української держави і це
сьогодні є особливо важливим До речі я
хотіла би подякувати усім людям які
сьогодні тут які виходять на майдани
площі по всій Україні і навіть за
кордоном Я знаю що виходить що дуже
багато людей які не до кінця вивчили
українську мову але
українська понад усе у їхньому серці бо
вони громадяни Української держави і
тому зараз я хочу попросити до слова
одного зі співавторів закону про
українську мову Микола
Княжицький Слава Україні
Слава сьогодні справді символічний день
сьогодні 30 років від прийняття
декларації про державний суверенітет
України і знаєте сталося так що всі ці
30 років не давали українському народу
прийняти важливі закони ми не мали до
минулого року закону про українську мову
був у 89 році так званий закон про мови
але це був перший закон про українську
мову прийнятий за часи української
незалежності
прийнятий напередодні дуже важких часів
він він вступив в силу в цей день рівно
рік тому я згадую як це було якби не
Віра ентузіазм і сила Андрія парубія ми
не мали б цього закону якби не підтримка
багатьох політичних сил які в той час
були в парламенті оце очевидний Блок
Петра Порошенка на чолі з президентом
Петром Порошенком який завжди був
прихильником сильної української держави
цей Народний Фронт цей Свобода прапору
якої я бачу тут депутати якої голосували
в залі це ї Батьківщина я бачу тут
демократичну сокиру молоду українську
політичну силу яка разом з нами виборює
нормальне майбутнє для нашої
держави бачу тут Національний корпус
бачу конгрес націоналістів багато
прапорів є тут знаєте мені казали
давайте приходимо без прапорів на що я
відповідаю Ні ми українські патріоти ми
здорова сильна нація ми політична нація
яка має сильні політичні партії і рухи і
ми точно знайдемо в собі сили щоб
напередодні тих викликів які є не
поборювати один одного А разом боротися
з ціією навалою антиукраїнських сил всіх
цих опзж всіх цих напівпродажних слуг
всіх цих бужанських тому що це наша
країна це наша Україна і ми обов'язково
переможемо правда
так без української мови державу не
побудуєш саме тому поляки мають польську
мову як державну угорці Угорську а
росіяни Взагалі всі мови забороняють і
закрили останню українську бібліотеку ми
так діяти не будемо ми Дбаємо про
національні меншини ми Захистимо кожну
меншинну мову але ми зробимо так щоб
українська мова в українській державі
живалися На кожній вулиці в кожній школі
в кожному магазині і у Львові і в
Харкові і в Донецьку і в Луганську і в
Одесі тому що це Наша Мова це наша
держава і це наше майбутнє Слава Україні
Ям
Слава шановні друзі народні депутати
зараз повертаються до залу для того щоб
там відстоювати українські національні
інтереси Ми стоїмо тут до 15 години наші
колеги будуть з всіх політичних
проукраїнських сил будуть підходити до
нас для того щоб знайомити з тим що
відбувається зараз в залі а ми стоїмо
тут до завершення цього засідання Цього
дня тобто до 15 години сподіваючись що
все-таки не буде сьогодні ухвалено
навіть винесено цей закон Микола
кляжицький зробив добру передличку
політичних сил які є тут на Майдані але
тут є не тільки політики тут є люди які
представляють громадськість Так так я
знаю що тут є представники такогорух х
відсіч який в мене назавжди асоціюється
з відстоєння української мови відсіч ви
є
є я знаю що тут є представники руху
опору капітуляції Це ті хлопці з якими
ми разом виходили Цієї осені Цієї зими
для того щоб не
дати зеленському і його компанії продати
Україну на міжнародному рівні Я
переконаний що такого роду акції які ми
відбуваємо сьогодні які ми відбували
минулого в минулому році в кінці
Минулого року роблять нас сильнішими
вони нас згуртовують Я дуже радий що
разом з нами і є представники
інтелектуальної еліти запрошую до слова
директора інституту української мови
Національної академії наук пана Павла
Гриценка Слава
Україні Слава дорогі
друзі Національна академія наук України
з вами і тут є десятки її представників
це та академія яка народилася разом з
Україною в 18-му році і та у академія
яку сьогодні поступово крок за кроком
хочуть знищити Як би не було складно як
не і викручували руки академії але
науковці завжди стояли на одному в
Україні має бути одна державна мова і це
українська мова а
інша нам сьогодні підкидають різні
версії що поступіться там а поступіться
там не можемо
поступитися і не
поступимося українська мова має панувати
в усій
Україні в усіх сферах суспільного життя
і ці половинчаті рішення які намагаються
нам нав'язати це шлях назад це шлях в
російський мир якого ми уже
наїлися Путін зробив злочин
гуманітарного плану він пов'язав мову з
кров'ю За українську мову нищили і
нищать але не просто за мову сьогодні
українська мова це
нашого вибору вибору нашої
самостійності вибору нашого
європейського спрямування ми європейська
нація Ми живемо в Європейському просторі
і нам назад повертатися не тільки
некомфортно а це рівно нашому знищенню
Тому я хочу щоб кожен із вас усвідомив
Ми стоїмо не тільки за українську мову
Ми стоїмо за наш за наш
геополітичний європейський вибір Ми
стоїмо за наше
майбутнє чи буде Україна як держава чи
ні чия мова того держава нам нав'язують
російську мову щоб це була колонія Росії
ми відстоїмо тільки мову українську і я
не погоджуюся дорогі друзі що де На
деяких плакатах написано мова або смерть
ні українська мова і життя українська
мова і
перемога Я запрошую вас
усіх подумати над одним
питанням чому у Польщі прем'єр-міністр і
президент поляк
чому у Румунії президент і Прем'єр
румун А ми що
гірші чи в нас немає кадрів Які би
можуть
українсько-центричні українськи
зорієнтовані які не будуть ламати
Україну через коліно Ми не можемо
висунути із наших рядів свого президента
і свого прем'єра і свого голову
Верховної Ради який не буде зраджувати
інтереси
України стоїмо на одному Україні
потрібне керівництво українсько
центричне українськи зорієнтоване яке
буде відстоювати Україну в усьому у
Малому і великому Слава Україні Героям
слава
Павло Юхимович як директор інституту
української мови Національної академії
наук України є мегакрутий насправді
напевне він в Україні знає про мову і
про її відтінки чи не найбільше рада я
вам скажу секрет для державного бюро
репресій він малоизвестный
человек так що дбр намило в тому ж числі
якщо вони не знають які є українські
вчені що ж а я маю приємність запросити
на цю
сцену людину яка була моєю вчителькою в
школі чим я шалено пишаюся А пізніше
вона стала міністром освіти України Ліля
Гриневич шановна
громадо Час іде по спіралі але є
цінності які ніколи не можна здавати по
спіралі тому що я згадую як ми приймали
закон про
освіту як складно
виборювалося природнє право щоб в
Українській державі в школах діти
навчалися і володіли українською
державною мовою Я хочу нагадати тим хто
зараз
посягає на те законодавство яке вдалося
тоді великими зусиллями створити в першу
чергу цей закон був відстояний у
венеційській
комісії цей закон був відстояний в
конституційному суді
України він не порушує він розширює
права наших дітей
зросійщині міста які піддавалися
десятками і десятками років планомірній
політиці зросійщення у школах нарешті
мають стати і стають
українськими і сьогодні українська
молодь володіє багатьма мовами закон дає
можливість маленьким дітям починати з
материнської мови і це правильно але при
цьому вони починають вчити державно
держави в якій вони живуть і вже стаючи
старшими можуть термінологічний апарат
всі предмети навчальні вивчати державною
мову це їм дасть можливість потім бути
успішними в житті будувати свою кар'єру
вступати в найкращі університети але я
хочу зараз вам всім ще одну річ сказати
цей закон не тільки хоче
перекреслити деякі прогресивні норми
пов'язані з вивченням української мови
він пропонує ще одну новацію в лабках
ввести деякі предмети російською мовою в
усіх школах України тому що ми
передбачали що в деяких школах наприклад
з поглибленим вивченням іноземних мов
Європейського Союзу школи з англійською
мовою французькою німецькою зможуть
кілька предметів наприклад
країнознавство чи інші вивчати тою
англійською французькою чи німецькою
мовою щоб наші діти які обов'язково
стануть як і Україна громадянами країни
Європейського Союзу України бо це наша
стратегічна мета вільно почувалися в
європейській спільноті і знали всі мови
так от абсолютно
таким обманним шляхом вони хочуть
замінити цю норму на російську мову тому
Дорогі друзі це дуже небезпечні зміни і
ми маємо зробити все щоб їх не допустити
Дякую вам що ви прийшли сюди Дякую за те
що сьогодні є люди які не здадуть украї
Слава Україні Героям
Слава це якраз є отой от момент коли
говорить Міністр освіти про українську
мову а комусь та українська мова заважає
ви знаєте оцей законопроект який
пропонує нешановний пан
бужанський мене питаються а про що він а
я кажу коротко про що він він про те що
бужанський вважає наших дітей
недорозвинутими Він вважає що наша
Молодь не здатна в школі вчитися
української мови але що більше він хоче
щоби молодь і була на майбутнє
недорозвинутою тому що якщо діти не
вчать в школі української це означає що
в них проблеми зі здачею ЗНО у них
проблеми потім щоби йти на якісь
державні посадибо українська кострубата
у них проблеми навіть у запов
декларацій податкових хто там стає
підприємцем Так що я скажу Я знаю що
наші українці не те що розвинуті наші
українці унікальні і кожен може вивчити
стільки мов скільки хоче і українська
мова Вона має звучати по всьому світу бо
де би ми українці не приїхали що нам
передусім кажуть Яка у вас унікальна
мова яка вона красива тож щоби Україна
звучала по всьому світу треба багато
хороших людей і маю приємність знову
запросити на цю сцену свою коліжанку з
якою разом Ми були у Європейському
молодіжному парламенті Україна а
сьогодні вона моя колега народний
депутат України фракція партії голос
Наталя
піпа
Слава Україні Героям слава чесно мені
дуже сумно що ми на 29му році
Незалежності приходимо тут щоб пояснити
хоча близько 80% українців визначили що
єдина державна мова в Україні українська
і це крапка Я дуже хочу щоб це був
останнє скликання в якому взагалі
піднімаються такі питання ми цей
законопроект разом з колегами тричі
провалювали в гуманітарному комітеті
Також я є комітету освіти науки та
інновацій я його там не підтримувала Я
хочу щоб ми говорили про контекст Як
змінювати Україну як робити її більш
сильною економічно геополітично щоб
наших сусідів не залишалось сумнівів я
впевнена що ми це можемо зробити і саме
мова освіти є В тому
визначальною ніяких єдина державна мова
для вивчення єдина державна мова для
спілкування і вона Головне щоб вона була
популярна і нас Ми впевнені ми знаємо
точно що нас не тисячі а мільйони і та
ті сум ті сумнівні результати сумні які
були на останніх парламентських і
президентських виборах Ми мусимо всі
наступні змінити кожен хто має в собі
силу Я вас дуже прошу ви тут якраз
громадські активісти нам в політиці
бракує сильних активних свідомих людей
насправді цьому в Верховній Раді мене
питають Наталю А що найскладніше в
Верховній Раді кажу знаєте там дуже мало
України Дякую що ви тут з вами України
стає більше і хай вона буде достатнь щоб
ні в кого не було сумнівів що Україна
сильна Слава Україні і досить нам ховати
свої героїв нам треба робити цю країну
сильнішою міцнішою Слава Україні Героям
[музика]
слава А ви знаєте оце той момент коли ти
приходиш захищати українське і ти
розумієш що всі свої довкола що свої
стоять переді мною перед сценою що свої
підходять ось тут до сцени промовити
слово тож Я запрошую на цю сцену свою
одногрупницю з факультету міжнародних
відносин Львівського національного
університету імені Івана Франка а тепер
мою колегу по парламенту політична
партія голос Галина
Васильченко
[музика]
друзі Доброго дня Ви знаєте хоча
сьогодні парламент не планує розглядати
цей ганебний закон пана бужанського ми
все рівно зібралися тут за що я вам
просто шалено Дякую це означає що нам не
байдуже і нам не какає разница бо для
нас дуже важливо Якою мовою будуть
вчитися розмовляти ми з вами і наші діти
як мама двох дітей які навчаються в
школі для мене це принципове питання
адже мова визначає нашу ідентичність це
одна з основних ключових цінностей нас
українців тільки українська мова і Я
закликаю сьогодні звертаюся до всіх
народних депутатів із інших фракцій які
десь Можливо в подумках мали
підтримувати цей закон Якщо раптом його
чи сьогодні чи завтра Чи вже з вересня
не дай боже винесуть на голосування щоб
вони в жодному разі не підтримували і ми
звичайно разом з вами будемо відстоювати
це питання щоб тільки українська мова
принагідно хочу всіх вас привітати з
30-ю річницею проголошення декларації
проголошення
незалежності суверенітету України слава
Україні тримаємося всі разом і ми завжди
[музика]
переможемо дуже символічно що ми
сьогодні зібралися під стінами
українського парламенту Я маю величезну
надію що прийде о той момент коли всі
450 депутатів Там будуть не просто
українцями за записом у паспорті А що це
будуть депутати так само у Україною у
серці і кожне голосування кожен
законопроект і кожна поправка буде
голосуватися за чи проти лишень
враховуючи інтерес Української держави і
громадян
України я пишаюся що у нас є люди які з
першого демократичного скликання
Верховної Ради незалежної України маючи
за спиною купа комуняк які тільки і
чекали як
ножем стукнути у спину крок за кроком
відборювали вигризали Україну для нас
для майбутніх поколінь тож Я запрошую до
слова депутата багатьох скликань
Верховної Ради але головне депутата
першого демократичного скликання
Верховної Ради незалежної України борця
за українську державність і українську
мову Іван
заєць
шановні пані і панови сьогодні Великий
день для України 30 років тому Верховна
Рада ухвалила Декларацію про державний
суверенітет України цією декларацією ми
тоді звістили світ що прямуємо до
створення своєї власної держави Але ми
не тільки заманіфестували свою волю на
незалежність України декларація стала
тоді тим документом яка накреслила шлях
досягнення нашої цієї мети мети за яку
боролися дуже і дуже багато людей
декларація стала переломним моментом у
тих новітніх національно-визвольних
змаганнях тоді ідея Незалежності яка
жила на велелюдних майданах перекочувала
у владні коридори і під тиском народу
створилось такий унікальний консенсус на
те щоб створити Українську Державу і ми
не змарнували тоді свій шанс ми не
розтриінькали енергію свого народу а ми
скористалися вікном дуже коротким
можливостей історичних і утворили
державу здавалось би що нам робити зараз
святкувати шанувати батьків декларації
батьків держави згадувати попередників
віддавати їм
шанулоклонятися нашим теперішнім воякам
теперішнім волонтерам теперішнім людям
які ведуть боротьбу на збройному фронті
із Росією але ми мусимо сьогодні
тривожитися і за долю держави і за долю
нації за долю України бо Росія
розв'язала війну не для того щоб
поставити маріонетковій уряд в Україні а
вона розв'язала для того щоб знищити
українську державу ліквідувати її
знищити українську націю бо українська
російська влада розглядає Україну як
екзистенційного ворога Вони думають так
якщо існує Українська незалежна держава
То Росія як Імперія існувати не може і
це правда тому вони пішли війною на
знищення і легковажити тут не треба тому
ми й тривожимося тим що керівництво
держави тривожимося тим що теперішні
політики забули про війну
почали розмови про пустопорожні про мир
насаджують пацифічні настрої у нашому
суспільстві понижують рівень
обороноздатності країни Так ми не
виграємо війну так ми не збережемо свою
державу Але ми тривожимося не тільки тим
що відбувається сьогодні на воєнному
фронті ми тривожимося тим що
відбувається все середині самої України
голову підняла п'ята колона підняли
проросійські ворож сили і влада слуг
народу потурає цим силам вона сьогодні
замість того
щоб скріплювати українську національну
ідентичність яка а саме у першому
розділі декларації говориться про те що
українська держава твориться у річші
європейської державотворчої традиції як
держава національного типу що держава
мусить захищати держав національну
державність України
що мусять різні особи там громадські
об'єднання партії відповідати якщо вони
торпедують національну державність
України Так от замість того щоб
посилювати нашу ідентичність а в першу
чергу треба посилювати українську мову
бо мова є найбільшим будівничим нації і
найбільшим будівничм нашої
держави наша влада сьогодні розв'язала
по суті наступ на українську мову і тому
ми тривожимося тим що в Верховній Раді
завтра будуть вони розглядати цей закон
бужанського це не просто простріл там у
якусь окрему особу це постріл у нашу
державність у наше майбутнє Ми повинні
чітко заявити цим колобораціоністам і
ворогам України що вони мітять цими
законами цією боротьбою з українською
мовою себе кає воним ка какає новим
тавром і наше завдання полягає в тому
щоб люди постій бачили Це тавро на
їхньому чолі щоб вони не ховалися за
різними словами бо я стривожений тим як
ставляться наші політики до долі
української нації мови вони
виправдовуються тим що начебто
підняли це питання бо будуть вибори
нічого подібного ворог знає куди бити
Він знає що постріл у мову - це постріл
у націю Це постріл Українську Державу і
не сьогодні не сьогоднішній день а
постійно впродовж усього незалежницького
періоду Вони все робили для того щоб
українська мова не стала державною щоб
вона не запанувала всіх сферах і на всій
території України тому я хочу щоб ми не
легковажили а однозначно заявили їм що
ми виходимо на велику війну на велику
війну іде не
будемо пацифістами бо це захист України
це захист української мови ми не можемо
втратити те за що полягли цілі поколін
українців за що поклали свої голову
теперішні наші вояки За що ми втрачаємо
дуже багато часу енергії коштів для того
щоб стримати Росію тому оцей внутрішній
фронт сьогодні для нас перетворюється у
основний фронт і я думаю що ми будемо
моблізовані до такої степені що ми не
дозволимо цим колабораціоністам чи
манкуртам чи ворогам все-таки
переглянути статус української мови і
нарешті я хочу хочу звернутися до
Конституційного Суду Конституційний Суд
не повинен зволікати з ухваленням
рішення щодо
конституційності мовного закону бо всяка
відтяжка в часі - це праця на ворога
конституційний суд Я я дивився їхнє
засідання він однозначно показав що цей
закон відповідає Конституції України що
цей закон був ухвалений З дотриманням
конституційних положень регламентних
тому я думаю що Конституційний Суд не
буде відтягувати ухвалення рішення десь
до осені чи там до наступного року а ми
з вами маємо мабуть прийти і завтра ми
маємо прийти Можливо ще навіть більше
ніж ми сьогодні при прийшли ми маємо з з
вами сьогодні врешті-реш формувати такий
широкий фронт для цього наступу на п'яту
колону сьогодні не треба підгортати один
там під когось іншого сьогодні треба
ставати Отак в шеренгу як ми ставали
наприкінці 80-х років минулого століття
коли утворювали Народний рух України
коли всі люди Хто любив Україну були на
майданах на площах вимагали Незалежності
Я сподіваюся що все-таки ми відіб'ємо
наші позиції бо це позиції майбутнього
нашої нації Я сподіваюся що ми звузимо
сферу діяльності ворогів до якоїсь точки
і все буде нормально але не треба
сслаблятися треба мобілізуватися повна
мобілізація це урок із тих змагань кінця
80-х90-х років за державу на фінальному
етапі виборювання України потрібна була
максимальна мобілізація всього народу і
ми тоді забезпечили цю мобілізацію Я
вірю що ми сьогодні так само вийдемо на
цей високий рівень Слава
Україні
Слава
А в мене тут єдиний висновок зі слів
пана Івана мова зброя мова зброя мова
зброя мова зброя мова зброя мова зброя
мова зброя ви як ви знаєте сьогодні
вранці прокинулася і надибала дуже
гарний пост який каже що треба щоби усім
мовам були рівні умови для розвитку а
виявляється запровадження української в
школах це дискримінує інші мови зокрема
Московську мову і там хтось гарно так
написав каже Ну давайте щоби дійсно були
мови в рівних умовах для початку
Московську мову заборонимо Так 300 років
поспіль як забороняли українську мову а
тоді будемо говорити про рівність і
зараз дуже важливий момент Ми не
говоримо про побут Ми не говоримо про
родини Ми не говоримо про окремі випадки
сьогодні на намагається перекреслити
українську мову як
державну а в державі Україна державною
не тільки на папері Але й в житті має
бути Мова українська і для цього
потрібні добрі друзі поруч щоби пере
допомагали переходити на цю саму
українську мову То може ви вгадаєте кого
я зараз
анонсую Попереду жахи шляхи Попереду
жахи шляхи а в чоботях мозоляки А мені
то все байдуже біля мене справжній друже
біля мене друже тож Мені байдуже А як
доля припече поруч другове плече Юрко
журовей продовжуємо тільки ви співайте
разом зі мною готові вороги вже недалеко
вороги вже недалеко ГОСТ шаблі та
багнети остать шаблі та багнети а мені
та все байдуже А мені то все байдуже бо
біля мене справжній друже біля мене
друже тож Мені байдуже А як доля припече
поруч другове
плече Мамо рідна Україно Мамо рідна
Україна бог цілуй благаю сина Бог цілуй
благаю сина мені то небайдуже мені то
небайдуже рощавай не плач мій друже біля
мене друже тож Мені байдуже А я доля
припече поруч другове
плече Слава Україні Героям слава Ну що ж
Здоровенькі були мої дорогенькі вас
вітаю я Юрій журовель феноменальний
Західноукраїнський Рівненський гурт
адвінта вся творча спільнота ззнай наших
ми всі тут є всі наші хлопці і навіть
моя вагітна
[оплески]
дружина
нас сам сам я з Рівного і відверто скажу
останнім часом помічаю що дома в мами я
з'являюся набагато рідше ніж тут тобто
Все частіше і частіше я з'являюся в
Києві тому що Ну тому що треба
продовжувати боротись От і справа в тому
що
я тут не сам нас багато вся Рівненщина і
Волинь активних адекватних людей яким Не
треба пояснювати наскільки важлива
українська мова в українській Україні
наскільки важливий український мовний
закон
хіба що як маю хоч трошки педагогічний
досвід мені все частіше доводиться
доводити людям на пальцях на що схожа ця
ситуація Тобто взагалі оця от будівля і
ця вся ситуація схожа на такий
величезний екскурсійний автобус це його
кабіна з екскурсійною командою яку яку
ми як батьківський комітет все
суспільство кожних п'ять чи скільки там
років вибираємо і оця команда заповнює
кабіну і везе наших діток ми їх
довіряємо наших дітей і вони везуть її в
далеке в далеке майбутнє От і зараз ми
помічаємо що кожного разу треба Все
частіше заходити в кабіну і бити їх по у
руках тому що водій там відосиками нам
доводив що він Шумахер в турборежимі і
провозевших швидко і буде дуже круто
його екскурсоводи якісь там гіди весь
час його повертають наліво часто
гальмують знову ж таки вмикають ручник а
вже нещодавно ви всі бачите хтось там
хоче включити задню передачу у смердючий
галімий
совок от тому
тому ми тут Тому ми
представляємо не тільки живих героїв які
боряться загиблих героїв сучасних Ми
представляємо рівненщину і улаза самтюка
Костянтина острожського
Ніла
Хасевича тобто ці герої були завжди вони
боролися за Україну боролися за мову і
ми переможемо Слава Україні Героям слава
Слава Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
герою слава Слава нації Смерть Україна
посе
дякую А мені ще так подобається ця пісня
давно не гуляла сокира по вулицях міста
самого які І знаєте правда Ну колись нам
оттвінта це все заспіває коли ми точно
переможемо з мовою переможемо Українці
переможуть у нашій державі я маю велику
приємність зараз запросити на цю сцену
людину
за якого мені шалено прикро що він не є
депутатом теперішнього скликання людина
яка уособлює боротьбу за Українську мову
за українську націю За українську
державність і я дуже хочу щоби побільше
таких людей було і в парламенті і в
уряді всеукраїнське об'єднання Свобода
Андрій
ленко
Слава
Україні Слава ви знаєте коли уже було
оголошено про те що сьогодні біля
Верховної Ради зберуться люди яким не
какає разница люди які захищають
українську мову то уже з Верховної Ради
сказали що нібито вони сьогодні не
будуть розглядати цей ганебний закон
бужанського але ви знаєте Я вважаю що
абсолютно недаремно ми зібралися ну
по-перше ці зелені чорти постійно
брешуть І як воно там буде ми не знаємо
тому що вони брешуть весь час тому ми
зібралися тут щоб у них навіть думок
таких не було по-друге вони мають
розуміти що в будь-який день коли вони
собі надумають подібні законопроекти так
звані виносити на голосування Ми будемо
тут завжди ми будемо тут і ми будемо
робити так щоб вони розуміли що руський
мир в Україні не пройде Що тут буде
Україна а Україна тут буде тоді коли
буде українська мова тому що там де є
українська мова там російські танки не
пройдуть там де є українська мова там
буде завжди українська держава і коли
сьогодні Вони
намагаються лізти до української мови То
вони мають розуміти що вони дратують
звіра Вони мають розуміти що ісім років
тому ми виходили на мовний Майдан коли
при владі була не оця от Зелена чепуха А
коли при владі був Режим Януковича і ми
бирлися з беркотом За українську мову і
Ми стояли до кінця За українську мову і
ми перемогли ми знесли той
антиукраїнський режим ми відмінили той
ганебний з ікон Ківалова колісниченка
який ви тоді протягнули і зараз ми
переможемо Тому що це наша земля Тому що
тут Наша мова Тому що тут мають бути
наші закони так було і так буде завжди
Тому Дякую вам всім за те що ви сьогодні
тут ми будемо боротися за нашу мову Я
буду виходити За українську мову стільки
скільки ке буде потрібно тому що
по-іншому просто бути не може Я
переконаний що ви так само думаєте і ми
обов'язково переможемо Слава
Україні і слава нації
смертьга Андрій добре нагадав про
московські танки бо Московська Федерація
має свою доктрину закріплену у всіх
конституційних і різних інших документах
де гласіться там где ступила нога
русского человека там руская земля там
де російский інтерес Там російська земля
там де Московська мова там Московська
земля і сьогодні говорити українською це
є самозахист саме тому так багато наших
захисників зокрема і моїх підопічних
свідомо почали переходити на українську
мову щоб своєю українською бити ворога і
не давати йому приходити на нашу Землю І
тим паче прикро коли високі урядовці
мало того що кажуть кака я разница там
не стреляют мир в очах Путіна починають
нападати дальше і на українську мову Я
розумію що в декого є третя хромосома і
декому не дано вивчити українську але в
Україні має бути українська мова бо її
сьогодні захищають наші воїни і мова
захищає наших захисників саме про це Я
запрошую до слова захисника волонтера
Мирослав
Гай Слава Україні
ю Слава друзі Я дуже щасливий що нас
сьогодні тут так багато хай слуги народу
і пасіпаки Кремля знають що в будь-яку
секунду нас буде ще більше Вони не
розуміють що своїми діями своїми
нападками на мову своїми
антиукраїнськими антидержавницькими
законами вони змушують нас виходити на
вулицю і готуватися до боротьби
українська мова - це тільки частина
проросійського реваншу подивіться що
відбувається останнім часом відбувається
переслідування ветеранів і волонтерів ми
розуміємо що замовником таких
переслідувань може бути тільки Путін
сьогодні знову будуть суди над
ріфмайстром Андрі
Антоненко офіцером сил спеціальних
операцій над Кузьменко Яною дугар ми
бачимо переслідування опозиції ми бачимо
переслідування пятого президента Петра
Порошенка ми бачимо що Вони намагаються
переглянути статус державної мови мови
української мови хто пише сценарії
слугам народу тільки Кремль це вже
очевидно що Вони намагаються поступово
звати план Російської федерації по
поверненню України до геополітичного
впливу під російську федерацію
відведення військ у нас кожного дня
загиблі на фронті у нас за 10 днів 27
поранених п'ять загиблих президент
мовчить він займається ремонтом дитячих
садочків продає готелі українські
розповідає про приватизацію відбувається
напад на українську мову президент
мовчить відбуваються напади нази ю
президент мовчитьнь президен ганьба
ганьба ганьба ганьба це ганьба ганьба це
системний напад на кожного з нас на
кожного українця на наше з вами право
називатися українцем і хай вони знають
що якщо цей закон не дай боже буде
прийнятий ми винесемо їх звідти ногами
вперед Ви згодні зі мною
саме тому рух Оперу капітуляції
підтримав сьогоднішню акцію більше того
Друзі на днях ми видали велике звернення
від всього громадянського суспільства
яке
підписало Ульма великих відомих знаних
людей як пан маринович як Йосиф зісельць
як Володимир
осленко це звернення до всіх
проукраїнських сил до всіх національних
сил нам час єднатися друзі нам час
єднатися для противостояння російському
реваншу тут і зараз готуємося з вами до
боротьби бо осінь буде гаряча Слава
Україні Ми переможемо
що ж и як главный терорист планеты Я
представляю головну загрозу президенту
зеленському і головного оборонця
української мови і української
державності п'ятий президент України
Петро Порошенко і Марина
Порошенко
горошенко
Порошенко Слава Ісусу Христу
слава Слава Україні Героям
слава Дорогі брати і
сестри Дорогі
однодумці дорогі
одномовці
я я вітаю
вас
святом святом
підписання Декларації про державний
суверенітет України
30 років
тому 16 липня
90го цій будівлі Верховної Ради
України була
підписана і прийнята декларація про
державний
суверенітет це не просто нормативний
законодавчий акт
це дорожня
карта для
Путіна політичної катастрофи Путіна X
сторіччя
це звони руйнації Радянського Союзу і
дзвони
відновлення державності
України 30 років
Це величезний символ для всього
українства і я дякую кожному з вас
який прийшов на майдан
Конституції для того щоби не просто
святкувати а
тут в Києві на Майдані Конституції
боронити Українську
державу бо не тільки наші воїни на
фронті віддаючи життя боронять
українську
землю тут ми з вами
кожен день і кожну
годину маємо захищати Українську державу
це символ як я
сказав Але п'ята колона
Кремля представники якої засіли в тому
числі в цій
залі також дуже добре розуміється на
[музика]
символізм і саме
тому саме
сьогодні їде до окупованого
Криму І саме тому саме
сьогодні вони представники цієї п'ятої
колони дивної антиукраїнської
коаліції слуг народа і
опзж спробували
поставити Закон про скасування
української мови і лише рішуча ваша
Воля зруйнувала цей
сценарій Я вітаю вас всім першим кроком
до нашої Перемоги ви
[музика]
найкращі
Порошенко
порошенкоже
дкую скажіть мені будь ласка А чому вони
вирішили це зробити саме
зараз бо вже 14
місяців при
владі Ця так звана команда нових облич
які зазнала руйнівного краху і
продемонструвавши тим ким вони були з
самого
початку командою
антиукраїнців командою
ніхчем командою без
які штовхнули України в прірву
економічної
катастрофи які зруйнували українську
безпеку які зруйнували міжнародну
світову коаліцію на підтримку України
яка була побудована нашою
командою
яка
програла опір пандемії
коронавірусу продавши захисні костюми
кордон замість того щоби захищати
українців що треба робити на їх думку
Коли
відбулася ця катастрофа по всім
напрямкам треба витягати зпід сукна
мовне
питання треба знову
продемонструвати вірність і відданість
своїм замовникам з
Кремля і ми Наша команда наша з вами
які 5ть років
відбудовували фундамент української
держави які 5ть років
виводили Україну з стану мовної
літаргії які ть років відроджували
українські пісні на українському радіо
бо в 13-му їх доля складала лише 5%
жальогідних 5% які відновлювали
українську книгу які відновлювали
українську мову на українському
телебаченні де даючи їм можливість
просувати їх продукт російськомовних
Сватів і російськомовний серіал слуга
народунь ми ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ми відновили
і захистили україн мову в тому числі і
завдяки діяльності створеного
українського культурного фонду де біля
більше 3 000 проектів пройшли і здобули
підтримку перейшовши Вже на абсолютно
встановлені законам і нашою командою
квоти на мову Дуже дякую тобі Марино як
Колишній голова культурного
фонду
у
дякуємо
і я хочу навмисно
наголосити що я хочу подякувати всьому
творчому
колективу який
нарешті написав закон про українську
мову і на цій сцені хочу
подякувати представника цього колективу
представника фракції європейська
Солідарність Миколу
[музика]
княжинському і до
авторів він був на цій сцені до авторів
належить і Володимир втрович захисник
української
мови
а представник європейської
солідарності я дякую Андрію парубію який
як Колишній голова Верховної Ради
тодішньої провів цей закон через
Верховну
Раду і це справа мого життя і я пишаюся
що цей закон
підписав пятий президент України Петро
Порошенко пятий тамий п'ятий та смий
пятий та смий птий та смий Дуже дякую Я
Хочу наголосити що ми навмисно це
зробили після виборів для того щоби не
дати
політизувати державницьке питання
української
мови А що вони роблять Лише вчора вони
проголосували закон про проведення
виборів саме 25 жовтня місцевих виборів
Лише вчора а вже
сьогодні ставить питання що розколює
державу питання які руйнує державу
питання скасування української мови Я
Хочу
наголосити тут я чув про
цього чоловіка чи не чоловіка який
оголеним полюбляє
фотографуватися паном
бужанським
який думає що це він піднімає цей прапор
Я прошу не згадуйте і не пам'ятайте це
прізвище він
[оплески]
некчер Бо політичну
волю для цієї спроби
реваншу дали дві політичні сили перший
це
є Володимир
Зеленський він
неодноразово на своїх прес-конференціях
і на своїх відосиках обіцяв Реванш
обіцяв переглянути закон про українську
мову виконуючи побажання своїх партнерів
по коаліції із прокремльовських опзж ми
з вами не дамо це зробити Ми з вами
точно це зупинимо ми з вами
побудували і Захистимо українську
армію ми з
вами створили молилися і Дякуємо
господові за те що він нам послав
автокефальну православну церкву
[оплески]
України і це дуже
важливо дуже важливо бо українцям
повернуте право
нарешті молитися Богу українською
мовию і це
правильно і за відродження української
армії і за наказ про Контрнаступ в 14-му
вони ця антиукраїнська Влада проти мене
птого президента порушили кримінальну
справу
вони українська влада за розпалювання
міжрелігійно і ворожниче шляхом
створення православної церкви України
проти мене порушили кримінальну справу і
ще 25 справ і вони їм
залишилися тільки за Українську мову
проти мене порушити справу Але це як
сторінки нашої Української історії якими
я і моя команда моя команда та наша
українська команда пишається бо ми з
вами творимо
державу
отже отже Я дуже дякую кожному з вас що
ви не байдужі що ви не залишилися вдома
що сьогодні ви вийшли сюди під стіни
Верховної Ради і зупинили сьогоднішній
розгляд закону про мовний Реванш і ми по
жаємо що кожний раз коли ви будете
спробувати руйнувати українську
державність Коли ви будете спробувати
руйнувати українську мову Ми Точно
нікому не дамо це зробити бо будувати
державу - це наш з вами святий обов'язок
і ми
лянемося це
робити в день підписання Декларації про
державний
суверенітет впереду ще багато роботи але
фундамент
фундамент у вигляді армії фундамент у
вигляді мови фундамент у вигляді віри та
церкви нами З вами вже збудований І ми
його захищаємо а фундамент у вигляді
економіки фундамент у вигляді соціальної
політики фундамент у виглядіропе
і євроатлантичного руху який проводить
наша політична сила європейської
солідарності і наші партнери які
зібралися разом на цьому майдані і ті
кому не байдужа Україна а нас більшість
є запорукою того що ми точно переможемо
Дякую кожному з вас Софійко Як ти там
казала що там хто мову зачепить тому
куди
їхати заважає мова геть до Ростова
заважає мова геть до Ростова заважає
мова Гек до Ростова прожає мова геть до
Ростова прожає мова
геслава це дуже добре чути і зрозуміти і
на Грушевського і на банковій треба буде
ще раз нагадаємо перемога точно буде за
нами Разом до перемо
Разом до перемоги разом до перемоги
разом до перемоги
разомперемо Дуже дякую вам і Слава
Україні Героям
слава Ми стоїмо сьогодні до 15 години до
поки триває засідання парламенту ми
приходимо завтра сюди тому що завтра
знову буде спроба ухвалити цей ганебний
законопроект через звертаюся до вас
Приходьте і ви завтра о 9:30 знову на це
саме місце приводьте інших людей
покажемо всім що ми не дозволимо
російського реваншу в Україні покажемо
всім що разом сила разом сила разом сила
разом сила разом сила разом сила разом
сила разом силараз як історик Я знаю що
українці на землі нищили сотні років
нищили українську мову українці були
об'єктом геноциду влаштованого
комуністичним режимом але на українській
землі нищили не лише українців на
українській землі нищили ще один
корінний народ І продовжують нищити на
окупованій українській землі кримських
татар Я запрошую до слова рафата
чубарова голову меджелісо кримських
татар
[оплески]
сі дорогі
друзі є
бастіони які ніхто ніколи не має права
покидати от одним з таких бастіонів є
мова якщо хочуть вбити знищити якийсь
народ
в нього в першу чергу вбивають
мову потім вбивають колективну пам'ять
щоб люди забули Хто вони звідки
вони а потім в них забирають
територію так було багато разів цій
історії так було з нами кримськими
татарами ми не складали мільйони лю і
вони не стали чекати поки вб'ють нас
мову вони перше нас взяли і викинули
своєї
землі
півстоліття півстоліття у вигнанні ми не
мали своєї школи Наша мова була
заборонена книжки не видавалися бо для
них не було нашої мови і вони думали що
вони нас так вб'ють у вигнанні і ми не
повернемося не будемо знову прибирати
свою
землю ми вижили ми вижили Бо нам батьки
завжди
говорили що наша земля то є Крим і наша
мова є кримськотатарська мова Отже
минулі роки в цьому
парламенті ми зробили все для того щоб
нарешті в Україні
закласти фундамент для того щоб
гарантувати повне
повноцінне функціонування української
мови як
державної це для нас було усвідомленням
того що ми
укріпилися на одному рубежі і далі йде
відтворення територіальної
цілісності і далі йде подальше
спрямування до Європейського Союзу до
НАТО але бачите Вони ж теж мають своє
розуміння Вони ж
завжди У полоні своїх планів щодо
знищення українців і знову спроба
реваншу Я дуже дякую всім в Україні і не
тільки на цій площі зараз на площах
багатьох міст зібралися люди бо вони
розуміють що вони не можуть іти з цього
бастіону бопадалі буде Реванш по всіх
інших напрямках російської
агресії дорогі друзі Я не мрію я дуже
хочу і ми працюємо над тим щоб яко можна
скоріше відновити суверенітет
Української держави Над Кримом щоб яко
можна скоріше об'єднати весь світ
навколо України щоби повернути
Крим повернути відновити суверенітет бо
Крим Нікуди і не уходив щоб його
повертати Крим в нас Вони захопили вони
окупували його і ми робимо все для того
щоби оті цінності той фундамент який ми
закладаємо
щодо мови української щоби наскільки
українська держава зараз опікується
мовами корінних народів
кримсько-татарською мовою все те що ми
схвалили в цьому парламенті минулі роки
воно все спрямовано на те щоби повністю
укріпити українську мову як державну
єдину державну мову надати гарантії
абсолютного розвитку кримсько татарської
мови оскільки жодна з держав в світі не
може і не має можливості і права
опікуватися кримськотатарською мовою
окрім України бо наша кримськотатарська
Земля в складі Української держави вона
є невід'ємною частиною української
держави і українська держава буде
опікуватися кримськотатарською мовою і
це ми заклали в наших законах росіянам
це не подобає
вони хочуть знищити українську мову
протипоставляючи її кримськотатарській
мові ми їм це не дамо як не дамо їм і як
вони хочуть контролювати на довгі роки
Крим відновимо Крим ми
обов'язково внесемо зміни я не думаю що
з цим парламентом але відбудуться нові
вибори прийдуть справжні патріоти
України ми внесемо зміни до Конституції
України щодо Автономної Республіки Крим
Крим буде національнона територіальною
автономію у складі Української держави
це право корінного народу України
визначати своє свою автономію у складі
Української держави це обов'язково буде
А зараз тримаємо не
оборону тримає свої позиції накопичуємо
сили і ми дамо їм відсіч по всіх
напрямках Слава кримськотатарському
народові Слава українській нації Слава
Україні
Слава Україна Крим - це Україна Крим -
це Україна Крим це Україна Крим -це
Україна Крим - це Україна Крим - це
Україна Крим - це Україна Крим -це
Україна Крим -це Україна знаєте дехто
будував свою зелену виборчу кампанію
слова які ми різні як нас Треба
об'єднувати А я от сьогодні дивлюся на
оцей Майдан перед собою на цю площу на
ці прапори на цих людей я бачу що ми
об'єднані ми єдині і тих кому дорога
Україна і українська мова ми не різні ми
просто маємо кожен свій шлях але в кінці
кожного шляху для кожного з нас є
українська державність мені шалено
приємно сьогодні бачити прапори різних
державницьких політичних сил Можливо
десь раніше ми з чимось між собою не
погоджувались але я я тішуся що коли
стало питання бути в Україні чи не бути
бути в українській мові чи не бути
захищати нам Україну чи підняти лапки
всі по суті зібралися докупи саме це нас
об'єднує і треба давати в зуби кожному
хто намагається розказати які ми різні
Україна у нас одна і тому ми єдині І до
речі недарма я перед цим говорила про
сокиру яка давно не гуляла по вулицях
певного міста маю величезну приємність
запросити сюди дитячу письменницю
волонтерку А головне спікерку з питань
освіти партії демократична сокира татуся
бо українська
об'єднує Я не люблю коли мою мову коли
про українську мову говорять виключно в
контексті яка вона нещасна і згорьована
це не так
українська - це мова
любові мова
радості мова
боротьби мова сили мова
Перемоги українська пережила
імперії украї
пережила тих хто її вбивав і вбиває й
зараз українська переживей цю зелену
плісняву українська буде жити
віки ми живемо в демократичній країні і
демократія це в першу чергу можливість
обирати і Я особисто і ви і ми всі разом
Ми українці обираємо не
фінансувати інформаційну війну проти нас
Ми обираємо українську науку українською
мовою Ми обираємо українське мистецтво
українською мовою Ми обираємо українську
політику українською мовою Ми обираємо
жити українською мовою Ми гостинна
країна тут можуть знайти прихисток
будь-хто з різних країн світу але це не
означає що українці мають поступатися
своїми правами це не означає що ми маємо
почуватися в цій країні
чужинцями камеру чуть вперд українська
[музика]
єднає ми тут для того щоб показати владі
що жодні проросійські реванші не
пройдуть а спроби На жаль такі є знаєте
рівно рік тому тривала активна
передвиборча кампанія і я брав в ній
участь багато Їздив по Україні і справді
дуже часто використовувавце слово Реванш
ми застерігали українців від того що
обрання зеленої влади може стати
початком проросійського риваншу Я б дуже
хотів щоб ми тоді помилялися На жаль ми
виявилися правими На жаль всі наступні
місяці все те що робилося після приходу
до влади зелених є свідченням того що
вони дають можливість повертати Україну
в минуле оттут зараз зустрічаємося з
своїми друзями і всі кажуть Слухай знову
як в 2012му пам'ятаєте
так от насправді хочуть спихнути назад в
2012 хтось хоче спихнути нас назад ще
глибше в історію кудись в радянські часи
чи в часи Російської імперії і Тільки
наша згуртованість те що ми з вами разом
є зараз на заваді того щоб нас спихнули
в Це минуле через це закликаю вас
приходити на акції протесту на акції
протесту які стосуються захисту
української ідентичності які стосуються
захисту політичних опонентів теперішньої
влади через це закликаю вас бути разом
відчувати плече один одного Сьогодні ми
як я і сказав стоїмо до 15 години Але
закликаю бутий завтра тому що Точно
спроба ухвалити цей закон буде й завтра
завтра з від 9:30 до 15
[музика]
[оплески]
години бачите Сьогодні свято Сьогодні 30
річниця декларації про
суверенітет і таке важливе свято 30 30
років минуло з дня ухвалення рішення яке
стало початком незалежності України це
життя одного покоління і ми досі
зобов'язані виходити на захист ключових
речей для нашої ідентичності і ми будемо
це робити ще раз сьогодні стоїмо до
15:00ї завтра збираємося знову о 9:30 на
площі Конституції для того щоб захистити
одне з ключових конституційних прав
українців право спілкуватися своєю мовою
а зараз до слово запрошую журналіста і
народного депутата попереднього восьмого
с скликання одного з тих які впевнено
тиснув кнопку зелену кнопку за в момент
коли розглядався закон про функціонання
української як державної Сергія
Висоцького Дякую Володя Слава Україні
героям
слава я стою Зараз перед вами не як
політик не як журналіст не як член ру
руху капітуляції як простий Київський
хлопець з околиць з пролетарських
околиць де ніколи не було чутно
українською мовию простий хлопець з
околиць який
зрозумів коли йшли два майдани коли
Росія наступала на нас коли ми кожен з
нас об'єднувались на барикадах на фронті
у волонтерстві у політиці що єдиний
засіб ста українцем і творити Україну
навколо себе це віднайти її
всередині українська мова Ми кажемо що
це ДНК нації Але що ми вкладаємо в це
поняття українська мова - це те що
зумовлює Україну навколо нас українська
мова - це те що берігає наші кордони від
інвазії російського світу українська
мова - це не просто засіб спілкування
українська мова це засіб віднайдення
українців в самих
себе коли оці люди коли оці зелені
чоловічки коли оці бужанські медведчуки
і такі як вони кажуть нам про захист
російськомовний кажуть нам про те що
вони просто за права національних меншин
коли вони кажуть що вони хочуть просто
рівних прав для дітей будемо вводитись в
оману ми ми дуже добре розуміємо про що
вони кажуть Ми дуже добре розуміємо що
за ціми словами про якийсь захист про
якихось російськомовних дітей стоїть
одна ідея і це ідея під назвою Путін
веди війська саме це вони проголошують
коли вимагають зараз парламенті
скасувати закон про українську мову саме
Путін веди війська Росія прийди України
немає оце Вони мають на увазі вони
кажуть нам не виходьте на площу вони
кажуть нам не захищайте українську мови
вони кажуть нам що Україна може бути
будь-якою мультинаціональною
мультикультурною І двомовною про що вони
кажуть насправді вони насправді кажуть
про те що України тут бути не повинно що
тут повинна бути Росія все про простий
меседж Коли нам кажуть що Україна вам не
потрібна коли нам кажуть що мова
ідентичність наше національне
самоусвідомлення не має значення Коли
нам кажуть какая разниц що ми їм
відповідаємо Ми відповідаємо їм ніколи
ніколи ніколи Ми ніколи не здамося ми
ніколи не віддамо нашу мову нашу націю
наші культурні кордони ми ніколи не
перестанемо боротися за
Україну
знаєте якщо ви слідкуєте за новинами ви
бачите що останній рік відбувається
багато громадських акцій проти
капітуляції рух опе капітуляції
намагається виступати отим
координаційним центром який об'єднує
різні спільноти правих лівих якихось
людей які можуть мати різні погляди на
економіку я не знаю на якісь побутові
речі заради головної мети заради мети
щоб нашу Україну не здали Путін Мені
здається що питання об'єднання наших
зусиль питання об'єднання громадських
рухів політичних партій питання
об'єднання всіх тих хто готовий захищати
Україну Це зараз наш порядок денний
українців завж жди били коли вони були
роз'єднані але коли ми гуртувалися
навколо наших цінностей навколо наших
барикад навколо нашої держави коли ми
всі підкидали політичні суперечки
громадські суперечки якісь особисті
образи ніхто українців здалати не міг
тому я хочу закликати Я дуже радий що
сьогодні на цій сцені виступають
представники різних політичних партій
різних політичних рухів українці
об'єднуємось об'єднуємось для того щоб
відповісти на оцих зелених чоловічків на
оцю загрозу нашим широким українським
наступом нашим широким українським
фронтом який Ми створимо задля того щоби
жити в своїй національній
україномовній культурній державі І ще
одне ще півхвилини ми бачимо як зараз до
України повертаються облудні практики
політичних репресії ви бачили на цій
сцені п'ятого президента України проти
якого відкрити 24 кримінальні справи Тут
є Тетяна Чорновол яку режим Зеленського
хоче покарати за Майдан зараз в тюрмі в
СІЗО сидять ріфмастер Та Юля кузменко
сьогодні на 12 годину оголошений
позачерговий суд Я прошу дате ткищо
тільки що уточнили на 1шу годину суд над
Андрієм антоненком на 14:00 суд над
Юлією Кузьменко якщо ми не будемо
солідарні не будемо
захищати протиполітичних репресій оцих
громадян волонтерів українських
політиків тоди тоді нас просто розберуть
на запчастини суспільство громадяни
українці єднаємось єднаємось задля нашої
Перемоги Слава Україні Дякую
Слава
прогриміла надкра ною біда чорні
крила руський мірлиха орда іде війною
жерла Крим жере Донбас гейто
зброї тільки ми Ніхто крім
нас І це співають наші Захисники на
фронті тому я сьогодні хочу сюди до
слова просити і наших захисників зокрема
тут командир штурмової роти батальйону
Айдар А зараз член руху опору
капітуляції Ігор
[музика]
Лапін Слава Україні героя Слава
громадяни Я впевнений тут не население я
неодноразово це Кажу тут лише громадяни
сьогодні нащадки тих комуняк котрі під
червоними прапорами стріляли в потилицю
нашим дідам хочуть вистрілити в голову
нашим дітям ви знаєте якщо ми цього не
зробимо і не зупинимо їх цього не
зробить ніхто і тому наше головне
завдання Сьогодні як ніколи бути єдиними
у своїй
боротьбі я говорив неодноразово що
температуру для цієї хати потрібно
піднімати тому що вони не можуть
зрозуміти одного Україна Не здасться
російським окупантам для мене не є кака
разница тому що я є громадянин України і
в мене є паспорт громадянина України і
сьогодні те що витворяють наші так звані
слуги Ну як говорила письменниця Марія
Матіос я знала що український народ
мудрий але просто не думала що він на
73% може таке вчверити вчверили Тепер
нам всім розгрібати і ми це розгрібемо
але саме головне ми маємо бути єдиними я
бачу тут багато прапорів різних
політичних сил і нацкорпус європейська
Солідарність я бачу прапори руху опору
капітуляції Свободи я хочу сказати ви
знаєте отам десь я бачу прапор Росії під
ногами під ногами так так От він там є і
він має бути тому що Московська
федерація - це є ворог України Це є ті
хто сьогодні вступають на нашу землю
російський чобіт і для того хто не знає
хто в нас є агресором Я хочу нагадати та
Старо во на це Росія і там є місто
Ростов він
негумовий але файні вишиванки їм тут не
допоможуть тому що є дуже багато людей
які знають що криється за личинами нам
не страшні московські вочі нам страшні
московські гниди і їх треба душити тут
ще тільки вони не народилися Слава
Україні
Слава
Ану А вгадаєте кого я наступного
запрошую на сцену Не спи моя рідна
земля прокинься моя
Україно Відкрий свої очі у світлі
далеких
зірок то дивляться з темних
небес загиблі поети
герої всі ті що клали життя за майбутнє
твоє
Фома
Мандри Доброго дня брати і сестри Слава
Україні героям
слава я хотів би почати з
пісні яку я дуже
[музика]
люблю
оюлу вона калина
похилилася чогось наша славна Україна
зажурилася а ми тую червону калину
підіймемо а ми нашу славну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо а
митую червону калину підіймемо а ми нашу
славну Україну гей-гей
розвеселимо не
хилися Червона калина маєш Білий
цвіт Не журися славна Україна має
швіільний
рід а
митую червону калину підій Мемо А ми
нашу славну Україну гей-гей
розвеселимо а ми тую червону калину
підіймемо а ми нашу славну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо
ою полі ярої пшениці
золотистий
Лан розпоча Али стрільці Січові з
мозлями
там а ми тую ярою пшеницю і зберемо а ми
нашу славну Україну гей-гей
розвеселимо а ми тую ярую пшеницю і
зберемо а ми нашу славну Україну гей-гей
розвеселимо
як повітя в буйнесенький вітер з широких
степів і прославив по цілому світу
Січових
Стрільців а ми тую стрілецькою славу
збережемо а ми нашу славну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо а митую стрілецькую славу
збережемо а ми нашу слагну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо
моюлузі червона калина
похилилася чогось наша славна Україна
зажурилася а ми тую червону калину
підіймемо а ми нашу славну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо а ми тую червону калину
підіймемо а ми нашу славну Україну
гей-гей
розвеселимо Слава
Україні
Слава я хочу сказати два слова
ее є
біля нас вільна Європа вільна Європа -
це Союз національних держав кожна з
країн Це сильні потужні самодостатні
країни кожна з них має свою мову іспанці
говорять іспанською німці говорять
німецькою поляки говорять польською
Українці говорять
українською і так
далі ми тут стоїмо по суті по абсурд реч
як це може бути так що в державі
Україна до цього часу ми захищаємо нашу
рідну українську державну мову це
абсурд я би це
ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба Я
хочу попередити тих персонажів які
випадково мчасо
зараз потрапили в приміщення Верховної
Ради і мають якісь корочки Не чіпайте
базових речей які формують нас як народ
а нашу країну як державу Не чіпайте
їх Не чіпайте І йдіть геть взагалітоге
гелю ге гелю ге гелю ге гею ге зелю ге
ге зелю ге зелю ге зелю ге зелю гелю
гелю гелю гелю
гегеге цю пісню Я присвячую нашим воякам
українським
Героям
поетам громадським діячам всім хто
тримає українське небо над
Україною я тобі
скажу де
квітне Дивний
сад де срібляста ніч
тремтить у темних
водах у далекий
край лежить нелегкий шлях
доки хижа ніч кружля по
колу ві Захистимо україн Не спи моя
рідна
земля прокинься моя
Україно Відкрий свої очі у світлі
далеких зірок
це дивляться з темних небес
загиблі поети й
герої всі ті що поклали життя за
майбутнє
[музика]
твоє тільки два
шляхи один веде у
пекло інший шлях веде
тебе туди де
світ щоб знайти цей
шлях
Послухай своє
серце твоє серце
знає як його
знайти Не спи моя рідна
земля прокинься моя
Україно Відкрий свої очі у світлі
далеких зірок
це дивляться з темних
небес загиблі поети й
герої всі ті що поклали життя за
майбутнє
[музика]
твоє тобі
повім про мрію
солоту що палким
вогнем горить в моєму
серці про щасливий
край про
радісних
людей де життя кидає виклик
смерти
Не спи моя рідна
земля прокинься моя
Україно Відкрий свої очі у світлі
далеких зірок
[музика]
дивляться світлих
небес загиблі пояки
герої всі ті що поклали життя за
майбутнє
твоє Не спи моя рідна земля
прокинься моя
Україно Відкрий свої очі у світлі
далеких зірок
[музика]
дивляться пильно на нас із неба загиблі
герої всі ті хто так вірив у світ але
майбутнє твоє слава героям
[музика]
України слава Україні героям слава Не
чіпайте мову і оце ще ви знаєте я хотів
додати Я бачу перед Верховною Радою дві
будки там стоять хороші українські
хлопці але будки це не Українське будки
- це околоточе на Росії це треба буде
прибрати пізніше
Слава Україні Героям
слава героям України при слава слава
слава слава слава
слава маю велику
приємність також запросити на цю сцену
свою подругу але подругу передусім
пісенну і
волонтерську Я пам'ятаю коли була трохи
менша була така чудова Територія А де
була українська пісня Де були українські
відео де показувалося що модно це так
само українською тож Я запрошую на сцену
співачку волонтерку журналістку
засновницю території а Анджеліка
родницька вітаю вітаю друзі Слава
Україні Слава так приємно бачити усіх
вас так багато красивих натхненних облич
і очей які сяють знаєте я всім
скаржилася Під сценою кажу Ну от все
своє свідоме життя я митець який має
створювати світи і показувати їх вам
змушено витрачати на мітинги і боротьбу
але коли я бачу ваші очі Я готова
виходити ще і ще раз на цю сце
кующо друзі справді Мені здається що ми
неправильно якось поводимося коли ми
постійно захищаємося Ми повинні заявляти
про свої права а не захищатися бо ми
живемо на своїй землі говоримо своєю
мовою і ніхто не повинен вказувати як
вчитися нашим дітям звісно скільки буде
потрібно в українській мові наше плече
наші голоси наша енергія наша сила
стільки ми будемо збиратися разом і тут
і там люди яких я десятиліттями
зустрічаю на майданах і на мітингах А
давайте згадаємо яка вона лагідна
тендітна ніжна красива
зворушлива еротична
лайлива неймовірна багата соловіна і це
оголошення не наступ зірки яка буде
виходити на нашу сцену це все про нашу
мову мова
фантастична однак треба знаєте кожному з
нас пам'ятати що не тільки на мітингах
ми відстоюємо мову кожному треба купити
хоча б по одній українській книжці в рік
і тоді українське книговидавництво буде
жити
потрібно ходити на прем'єри українських
фільмів і тоді нам не треба буде просити
грошей у когось щоби знімати українські
фільми треба ходити на концерти
українських виконавців а не чекати поки
нам дозволять за якимись квотами десь
показати один раз свою пісню Ми повинні
відстоювати себе і ставити інакше
питання давайте введемо квоти на
іноземну музику в нашому
ефірі і зрештою українська мова як і
українська музика як і українське кіно
як і українська книжка як і
українець повинен перестати почувати
себе українською діаспорою В Україні ми
тут господарі Отже мова об'єднує мова
сильна і Я рада що ми
разом друзі мова
єднає звісно І знаєте коли ми вимагаємо
щоб нас
обслуговували в магазині українською
мовою або просимо когось дуже чемно ще
десь звертатись до нас українською Ми
багато чуємо всього поганого і ми
інколи махаємо рукою І думаємо не буде
вже Скільки можна боротися от просто
буду жити в своєму середовищі поруч із
своїми людьми і буде мені комфортно але
давайте будемо в ці моменти Коли така
слабкість десь з'являється всередині нас
згадувати про те як нас багато і що не
кожен вміє відстоювати мову країну
культуру державу Але якщо ми сильні то
ми повинні бути прикладом цієї сили і
територія теж була прикладом цієї сили
тому що нам не треба було якихось
законів депутатів квот Це була наша
ініціатива територія сказала українська
музика буде популярною в Україні і вона
стала популярною То може ми просто
неправильно якось ставимо питання з
приводу того що з нами відбувається Може
ми просто ховаємося від проблем і
чекаємо поки нам хто хтось нав'яже якісь
стереотипи і буде казати там на сході не
говорять українською мовою я 5ть років
не займалась кар'єрою в мене на це
просто не було часу Я спочатку війни
Росії проти України їжджу на Схід я
виступаю для військових для мирних
мешканців лугансьчини Донеччини Працюємо
з дітьми і я не чула щоби хтось кидав в
мене яйцями чи помідорами чи казав
иідіте со своєю мовой ні люди кажуть
Допоможіть нам вивчити українську мову
То чому цього не чує Верховна Рада чому
Це і я чую тільки я може треба не тільки
сидіти в своїх кабінетах А може треба
йти І спілкуватися з людьми і тоді ми
зрозуміємо що Україна не така як нам
показують її по телевізору Україна інша
Україна фантастична в Україні живуть
люди велити духо люди герої які віддають
своє життя за те щоб ми могли і співати
і жити і протестувати і приймати закони
але все щоб ми не робили Ми повинні
робити заради нашої країни тому що Мова
- це любов і Україна - це
любов Іще один Звісно що мова один із
таких же великих і потужних символів як
і герб як
і прапор і без мови немає ні нації ні
держави Ні України але ми навіть не
будемо про це думати тому що є мова є
держава є Україна І справді рік тому
коли приймався закон про функціонування
української
мови я стояла тут на сцені вела мітинг і
сьогодні в мене Дежавю Невже знову ми
тут Невже знову ми і змушені відстоювати
свою мову але Сьогодні особливий
все-таки день і через те що прийнятий
цей закон і тому що 30 років декларації
і наближається ще одна особлива для мене
дата 30тиріччя студентського голодування
в якому я брала участь пізніше Це
історики назвуть революція на граніті
але Уявіть собі все своє свідоме життя я
знаходжусь на мітингах і протестах
але ну і ви Дякую вам за те що ви тут
друзі але знаєте Я хочу щоби на
оптимістичній ноті ми закінчили наш ще з
вами спілкування і нагадаю вам про одну
Прекрасну дату цьогоріч виповнюється 50
років пісні яка стала символом України
червоній руті Давайте спробуємо її разом
заспівати я не готувалася співати але
вятрович сказав Ти мусиш це зробити Ну я
ж не можу відмовити вятровичу правда всі
готові давайте Хай ця пісня Буде нашою
подякою анжеліке родницькій яка зробила
українську музику відомою я від себе
особисто хочу подякувати Я хочу осоякую
хочу особисто від себе подякувати за те
що саме Територія А наповнила мою Юність
українською музикою в мене було такий
дивний трудовий досвід в 90-ті роки як
діджей і я мав можливість зробити навіть
українські
дискотеки дякуємо анжеліці і співаємо
Червону руту Ти признайся
мені звідки в тебе ті
чари я без тебе всі
дні у полоні
печалю може десь у
лісах я черзілля
шукала Сонце руту
знайшла І тебе чарувала
і всі разом
Червону
руту не шукай
вечорами ти у мене єдина тільки ти
повір Бо твоя
врода то є
чистая вода то є
бистра вода сині
Бачу я тебе
зна у Діброва зелени гучніше по Забутих
стежках ти приходиш до
мене і не треба
нести мені квітку
Надії бо давно уже ти ти ти ти ти
увійшов мої
мрії там там там там
Червону
руту не шукай вечорами
ти у мене єдина тільки ти
і
твоя брода тоє
чистая вода тоє
бистрая вода сині
її там там там там
Червону
руту не шукай
вечорами ти у мене
єдини тільки ти
повір Бо твоя врода тоє
чистая вода тоє
бистрая вода
си ще раз Дякуємо
анжеліці Слава
дякуємо
дякуємо дякуємо
знаєте Анжеліка згадала про те що в нас
з 90-х років в боротьбі мітинзі на
мітингах в мене така сама історія Тобто
ми постійно зобов'язані бути готовими
бути борцями бути бути боротися Це добре
що ми тримаємося в тонусі але знаєте з
іншого боку Я б хотів щоб мій
чотирилітній малий вже тепер боровся
тільки за якісь свої успіхи в спорті
успіхив в культурі успіхив в музиці щоб
йому не доводилося боротися за те за що
боролися ми щоб йому до не доводилося
виходити на чергові мітинги в захист
української мови чергові мітинги в
захист української армії якихось інших
вкрай важливих речей а для того треба
щоб ми перемагали а для того треба щоб
ми вміли відстоювати свою перемогу щоб
ми не віддавали ту перемогу яку ми
здобували а мова це наша перемога і ми
її здобули минулого року і ми її не
віддамо так так сьогодні звучить дуже
гарне гасло періодично мова єднає і
справді мова єднає мова об'єднює дуже
багать представників різних громадських
сил політичних сил Я дуже радий що тут
вони є присутні і з великою радістю
запрошую на сцену представника
Всеукраїнського Об'єднання Свобода
народного депутата пани олесара
севчука Слава Україні Героям слава
сьогодні в Києві під цим блакитним небом
і яскравим сонцем жовто-гарячим стоять
люди які мають в серці те що не вмирає в
серці ніколи не може вмерти любов до
свого рідного до того з чим ми
народилися перше слово - це мова Мова -
це наше генетичне Мова - це ми Мова - це
Україна здавалось бо це звичайні
зрозумілі речі для кожного для кожного
українця хто народжується на цій землі
але є люди яких Можливо в дитинстві не
так виховали Вони не читали українських
книжок вони хочуть в руський мир вони не
люблять Шевченка вони не шанують
Конституцію вони ті хто поплюжить нашу
українську землю бо справжні патріоти
ніколи в житті б не дозволили
собі пробувати познущатися над
найсвятішим над мовою і сьогодні ті хто
сидять в парламенті вони є тимчасові Хто
порушує питання української мови бо хто
не поважає українську мову того Бог
карає того люди цюраються і тому ми не
пробачимо я хочу сьогодні сказати що нас
дуже багато поі Україні Тут переді мною
є мої земляки і я дуже їм Дякую з
івано-франківська є дуже багато людей з
усіх куточків сходу заходу центра півдня
і півночі такі вічі відбуваються по
цілій Україні в Прикарпатті в Львівщині
Хмельниччині інших містах Чому так Тому
що нам не байдуже тому що ми тут з
простої причини Ми хочемо жити в сильній
країні А коли наша Україна є сильною
коли ми не зачіпаємо питання мови бо це
само по собі зрозуміле якщо би ще 30
років тому ми запровадили обов'язкове
навчання в українських школах і наші
діти вивчали українську мову Сьогодні ми
б навіть не дискутували про це Проблемне
питання І коли нарешті прийшов той
запізнілий час коли з 1 вересня всі ті
діти котрі ще не знають мови але вони її
будуть вивчати вони будуть змінювати
свої покоління свої родини навіть теж Ми
повинні сказати так а тим хто хоче
сказати Ні мало того дати їм по руках по
ногах по писку Як в народі кажуть і
копняка в дупу пробачте за мій такий
вислів некоректний але всіх тих хто
думає що ми українці не вміємо себе
захистити той дуже сильно помиляється бо
сильна і україн
Мова - це сильна нація тому віримо в те
що ми переможемо ми вже перемогли бо Бог
нам допомагає дає хорошу погоду дає
хороший настрій Ми всі з вами в
вишиванках як символ нашого українського
генетичного вбрання ми маємо в собі в
серці велику віру в те що ми праві А хто
правий той ніколи не зможе бути ніким на
пригноблений Він завжди переможе тому
нехай Україна голосно і голосно скаже
українській мові бути І це ніколи ніхто
не поміняє Тому що українська мова - це
Україна і ми розмовляємо українською
Слава Ісусу Христу Слава Україні і Слава
українській
мові Що ж а зараз я по прош підніміть
плакати щоби я побачила що у нас доброго
є Бо мені отут дуже подобається Петро
Олексійович казав не називати певне
прізвище тому я дещо переінакшу язик в
нешановного в свині і в корови а Україна
вимагає мову супер плакат давайте
поаплодуємо що ми маємо руки геть від
мови мова Наша безпека не чіпаємо
Калинову о маємо Шевченка мова рідна
слово рідне хто нас забуває
той у грудях не серденько тільки камінь
має Я думаю що там не камінь а там цілі
скелі в декого в грудях Ну нічого якщо
товкти Як казав каменяр то ці скелі
можна лупати і то дуже добре я Крим і
Моя мова українська аплодисменти це
правильно Мова - це зброя безпека і
Свобода
депутати голос за 236 д Це твій квиток
до Ростова так українська мова - це наша
зброя проти кремлівської українофобної
нечисті і маємо ще тут в Севастополі теж
навчали російською Ну ще трошки будуть
нас навчати українською так що ми ми
цього доб'ємося ми повернемося додому
знаєте мене особливо за Крим так жаба
давить Я буквально два рази там була
кожен раз Кримські татари захищали моє
право говорити українською мовою і так
хочеться повернутися додому в
український Крим правда додому в
український Донбас
правда а в цьому нам допомагають наші
Захисники Я кажу Захисники це сумарне
явище бо захисник колишнім не буває
хтось захищав 14-му хтось захищає на
фронті зараз але коли прийде момент і
треба буде як пані Оксана казала давати
в зуби й пописку то я думаю підемо ми
усі
тому Я запрошую на цю сцену справжнього
захисника України командира взводу
батальйону Кульчицького депутата
восьмого скликання але головне
співавтора закону про українську мову
Богдан
Матківський дорогий український народи
Слава Україні ро слава
світи тихий краю
милий моя Україна за що тебе
сплюндровано за що мамо
гинеш саме такі слова писав Тарас
Шевченко коли його боліло за нашу неньку
Україну коли його боліло за нашу мову
тому що Україна 300 років перебувала в
окупації в Московській окупації яка
прийшла прийшовши на нашу землю почала
тотальне знищення з початку мови
спочатку заборонили розмовляти
українською мовою навчатися на
українській мові пізніше заборонили
друкувати українською
мовою і на кінець
заборонили молитися українською мовою
все це відбувалося на протязі 300 років
і під
час цього катували вбивали
українців українську еліту українських
науковців вводячи сюда російськомовне
населення Саме так відбувалося довгий
час і ми кінцевому результаті здобули
нашу незалежність ми в кінцевому
результаті дійшли до цього першого кроку
який давав можливість і дає
нам будувати розвивати українську
державність українську Соборну
державність і що ми бачимо на 29му року
незалежності ми бачимо як знову
починається
намагання заборонити навчатися
українською мовою
це тоді коли якраз та держава яка 300
років окуповувала
Україну веде агресивні бойові дії коли
наші вірні хлопці захищаючи населення
України кладуть на вітар своє життя
це
тоді коли
судять моїх
побратимів за вказівкою Кремля В
Італії згадаємо Віталія Маркіна
Віталію марківу свободу Віталію марківу
свободу Віталію маркою свободу Віталію
марківу свободу
вітабоду
[музика]
і Сьогодні ці люди які уже давним
давно а точніше не
люди які давнимдавно вже в наших серцях
відійшли на смітник історії української
історії про яких ми не будемо
згадувати на чолі з діючим
президентом України Володимиром
Зеленським вирішили так як і 300 років
тому Московська держава вирішили
відкрити війну против українського
народу я знаю точно є
багато патріотів
українців які будуть боротися тому що в
14-му році нас не змогли
застрашити в 14-му році ми свідомо
пішли на війну з Російської Федерації Ми
не боїмося смерті тому що ми боремося за
Українську Державу і тільки боротьба за
державу дає можливість сподіватися що
наші діти виростуть незалежні соборні
самостійно економічно розвинутій
Українській державі з щирим українським
народом Слава Україні Героям
слава ну а зараз я маю особливу
приємність згадати всетаки що я главний
терорист цієї країни А що в декого від
слів там стріляють з їх уст починають не
тільки ноги трястися а починається
тотальна паніка але ви знаєте з чого все
почалося почалося все з того що людина
яка себе вважає верховним
головнокомандувачем України припхалася
на фронт переконувати що треба отвісті
войсь і коли до нього вийшли ветерани і
сказали ти чо неадекватний яке
відведення військ Коли тут стріляють
коли тут бомблять то той би їм почав
казати що я не і мені 42 роки ну Самі
знаєте так ось я маю велику
приємність представити ветерана якому
ото потерпілий казав і на захист якого
якого побратимів Ми з Марусю якраз і
зробили наш
стрім Сергій тамарін Ветеран полку Азов
керівник національного корпусу
київлава Україні геро
Слава Сьогодні ми тут зібрались через
дуже прикру необхідність дуже прикру
необхідність захищати українську мову в
Україні Якби абсурдно це не
звучало я сам з Харкова і все життя
говорив украї говорив російською мовою
але для мене не було жодних проблем
перейти на українську я вільно володію
англійською розумію
французьку мої друзі котрі співпрацюють
з іншими країнами навіть з Китаєм добре
вивчили китайську і тільки
мовсковська дегенеративна гнида навіть
якщо вона український парламентар на
жаль не може вивчити
українську Влада не
помічає пяту колону помічає відверті
антиукраїнські явища в українській
політиці не помічає медведчука котрий
нещодавно прийняв участь у круглому
столі з єдиною Росією я Нагадую що це
правляча партія Росії Яка на юридичній
площині в своїї країні ініціювали
анексію Криму Влада цього не помічає
Влада не помічає антиукраїнські
ініціативи бужанського не помічає голуба
Миру сивоху особистого друга
президента але їх помічає український
народ їх помічає українські патріоти їх
помічає українське суспільство і на жаль
Ми вимушені постійно доводити нашу
готовність боронити нашу
самоідентифікацію боронити нашу мову
нашу культуру боронити традиційні
українські сімейні цінності тому що
цього на жаль не робить
держава підвести підсумки можна дуже
коротко до тих пір поки на це на ці
антиукраїнські на ці ганебні явища не
буду звертати увагу відповідні органи до
тих пір українське суспільство буде
звертати на це увагу і буде діяти рішуче
і буде діяти дуже
стрімко це показала нещодавна спроба
шарія вийти на ули цю так далі буде з
усіма представниками опзж і інших
представників п'ятої
[музика]
колони український народ вже не перше
довів що може консолідуватись навколо
проблеми що може захистити країну
будь-яким шляхом І допоки хлопці на
сході хлопці та дівчата українські
захисники продовжують боронити наші
кордони
Ми не маємо жодного права не помічати в
серці країни в столиці антиукраїнські
ворожі дії і ми не маємо жодного права
цього не помічати І тим паче залишатись
байдужими тому я ще раз усіх
закликаю байдужість вбиває набагато
швидше ніж
зброя пам'ятайте нашу історію пам'ятайте
нашу культуру пам'ятайте наші цінності
бо в жодній країні світ бо в жодній
країні світу наскільки
б різними політичними поглядами не були
правляча структура ніколи не
підіймається питання про мову про
її сумнівну користь про культуру та про
історію і тільки в Україні на сьомому
вже році війни
це ганебне я ще ігнорується
владою не будемо байдужими Слава
Україні Слава
Нації Україна посе Україна под усе
Україна по усе Дякую
друзі Саме ці хлопці намагалися втримати
пана Сивого коли він летів на
підлогу тільки і він подав на них в суд
і їх тягають зараз по судах саме наших
ветеранів волонтерів чомусь тримають під
вартою а сьогодні нагадаю о
13:00 будуть намагатися продовжити
запобіжний захід Андрій Антоненко
ріфмастеро о 14тй Юлій Кузьменко і в нас
так багато ситуацій коли
судять в образі цих конкретних людей чи
конкретних дій судять саме українську
державу А тепер скажіть мені що оце за
суд зараз
відбувається над
книжкою книжкою про Василя
Стуса судять книжку в якій написана
Правда в якій є
документи тільки судять тому що той хто
долучився до в'язниці і по суті вбивства
Стуса сидить зараз в опзж в
парламенті тому сьогодні про це треба
говорити бо українські поети і
письменники це величезна частина України
і коли судять книжки то це нагадує
емські валуївські та інші укази тож Я
запрошую до слова того хто стоїть на
обороні Правди і хто стоїть сьогодні на
обороні Василя Стуса вахтан
Дякую дорогі друзі Сьогодні історичний
день кажуть що 29 років Українській
державі це неправда українській державі
102 роки 22 січня - це перший день
незалежності України у X столітті
наступний день - це 15 березня 39го коли
Карпатська Україна прогложє себе
Українською Державою з синьо-жовтим
прапором із гімном Ще не вмерла Україна
наступний день 30 червня 41го року коли
бандерівська ОУН проголошує доконаним
фактом незалежність під нацистською
окупацією це теж день який ми маємо
шанувати потім 16 липня день коли
малесенька щопта словами Василя Стуса 11
колишніх політз
Які ще вчора каралися комуністами за
своє слово за свою діяльність за свою
любов до України вони стали дріжджами і
запалили цю ганебну комуністичну
більшість пам'ятаєте
239 + О а чому плюс один 239 комуністів
плюс Владика агафангел
митрополит російської Православної
Церкви який сьогодні очолює Одеську
митрополію як і тоді 30 років Він завжди
був з російським світом тому 16 липня -
це день коли ми показали що навіть коли
нас мало ми перемагаємо і звичайно 24
серпня День який попереду але перед тим
днем 14 серпня Медведчук буде знову
намагатись засудити я би тут поправив
Софію вже не книжку не про книжку мова
знайді будь ласка на Ютубі відео з
останнього Засідання суду у п'ятницю там
судять не книжку там судять Василя
Стуса ви послухайте цинізм адвоката
адвоката медведчука Він каже що це Стус
любив комуністичну партію що це Стус був
перекінчиком а його клієнт Медведчук не
був шісткою комуністичної системи він не
розпинав поета він не боявся КГБ
ці осоружні і ганебні факти і багато
інших про які очевидно інші казали є
свідчення в того що реакція вона
будь-якої миті готова нам перегризти
горло але ми маємо стояти тут разом і
віртуально бути завжди разом щоби знати
що між нами є набагато менше протиріч
ніж нам здається і головний вектор
головний підмет на якому ми стоїмо Це є
Україна І якщо 11 поліце
зробили акт незалежності України
запаливши інших людей то ми теж
переконаємо що той хто за закон про
функціонування української мови як
державною той українець а той хто проти
той не українець його росі його
український паспорт для мене це
формальність всякі захарченки і мотороли
і Гіві теж мали українські паспорти і
Янукович має дотепер тому не той хто має
паспорт а той хто говорить і думає
українською Слава Україні Героям
слава не виплакати всіх кривавих сліз
моїй сердечній ленцій Україні обкраденій
сплюндрованої скрізь із ранами важких
чубіт на спині як Божа Мати все
перенесла родила мучилась ростила сина
не всім ти розум тіло зберегла але за
душу мову станем на коліна глянь скресла
наша Сонячна Зоря прозріли і ті чий
розум
засліпили за незалежність і мову станем
як стіна живі і мертві незборимі сили
вірш Василя Савченка А я маю велику
приємність зараз заповісти людину за яку
ми всі так довго боролися напевне вже
останній рік пам'ятаєте як призначали А
то Точніше як тягнули процес
призначенням уповноваженого з питань
мови спочатку призначили людину але не
дали Ані грошей Ані зарплати Ані
кабінету Ані структури потім з'явилися
достойні кандидати на уповноваженого з
питань мови ті які дійсно борються за
Українську мову не один рік але раптом
там з'явля якийсь кандидат абсолютно
нізвідки бо його пропихає міністерство
культури і інформації як воно там зараз
називається бо кожен раз міняють і
тільки нашою спільною позицією тільки
нашими вічи мітингами постами ми
вибороли що у нас нарешті уповноважений
з питань української мови дійсно живе
українською мовою запрошую на сцену
Тарас кремінь
Слава Україні Героям слава колись у
нашій історії вже забороняли мову і
таких прикладів у нас сотні але згадаємо
Великого Шевченка якому не
дозволили розмовляти українською мовою а
тільки писати і малювати і тільки на
29му році Незалежності народні депутати
Нового скликання спромоглися дописати ще
одне заборонити українським дітям ще
розмовляти українською мовою більш
цинічного антигуманного антиукраїнського
вчинку Я не бачу в історії новітньої
України і історії Європи в цілому Мені
здається що разом з цією акцію яка йде
на підтримку закону про українську мову
яки Ми підтримуємо ключові позиції
закону Про освіту Ми повинні сказати
категорично ні таким законодавчим
ініціативам які не мають нічого
спільного Ані ані з Україною ані з
освітою ані з нашим майбутнім я саме і з
Миколаєва Мені дуже приємно що
представники півдня України сьогодні тут
є чисельними Я хочу привітати всіх хто
прибув сюди зі сходу хто спостерігає за
нами із заходу Я хочу передати вітання
нашим оборонцям українським захисникам
які в цілодобовому режимі спостерігають
над дійством які вчиняють деякі наші
законодавці я публічно звертаюся до
народних депутатів України дев'ятого с
скликання шановні скаменіться вас обрав
народ України не для експериментів вас
обрали люди для того щоб Україна жила
вона розвивалася і мала успішне майбутнє
будьте самостійними тому в
парламентсько-президентській країни я
щиро бажаю усім нам щоб на тридцятиліття
декларації щоб на річницю мовного закону
жоден експеримент не пройшов Слава
Україні Героям слава
що ж багато ми говорили але я думаю час
для доброї української пісні тому що
таких пісень як у нас мало де є у світі
Я до речі скажу що науковці
підтверджують що від кількості народних
пісень визначають наскільки давня і
наскільки багата мова У нас в Україні
пісень сотні тисяч народних пісень Отже
це ще раз показує коріння нашої мови
силу нашої мови і якщо Какая разница на
яком языке говорить то чому не говорити
і не співати саме українською мовою
запрошую заслужену артистку України
Берегиню української пісні Оксану
стебельську
Слава Україні
друзі Слава За Україну за її волю за
честь за славу за
народ серце кров і любов все тобі
віддати в боротьбі всі разом за Україну
за її волю за честь за славу за народ
Слава Україні
Героям слава друзі Сьогодні ми всі тут
зібралися і ми не ділимося на професії
Ми навіть не ділимося сьогодні на
політичні вподобання Ми всі тут бо ми
українці сьогодні стільки друзів поетів
письменників музикантів політиків
викладачів і чесно кажучи я дивуюся коли
нас так багато І коли ми щодня говоримо
про те що ми хочемо жити в успішній
Щасливій країні нашою ідентичністю чому
нам постійно даються ці випробовування
нас постійно заставляють виходити на
майдани і гучно кричати про те що ми в
Україні хочемо бути
українцям коли ми
виходили з
метро Було дуже приємно підійшли до мене
кілька літніх людей бачить що ми йдемо в
товаристві з молодими людьми і кажуть як
добре що на Арсенальній так багато людей
вийшли бо ми вчителі які Уже на пенсії
все життя виховували молодь все життя
плекали їм любов до української мови і
тепер коли вийшли на пенсію і коли би
здавалося мали б відпочивати Ми мусимо
знов іти на майдани і захищати право
розмовляти української мови друзі я
дивилася у вічі цих викладачів а
особливо коли я дивилася у вічі тих
молодих людей з якими я сюди приїхала А
це студенти києвомолянської академії і
ось один із з них сьогодні тут зі мною
Сашко можна тебе Ось Олександр І коли я
дивлюся у вічі молоді коли я дивлюся у
вічі літнім людям я розумію що це наша з
вами персональна відповідальність за нас
з вами ніхто в цій країні не буде
обстоювати наших інтересів ви знаєте так
склалося уже більше 20 років музичному
проекту українські барви і мені
прийшлося дуже багато країн відвідати і
працювати з єльським і з гарвардським
університетом ви знаєте яка гордість
Коли ти приїжджаєш у Гарвардський
університет і розумієш що там є
Український інститут тобто люди за
кордоном так відстоювали нашу
ідентичність нашу мову створювали
культурні центри освітні осередки А ми з
вами тут боремося за право нею
розмовляти і
вчитися ви знаєте ще напевне з десяток
років тому ми думали що Ну якось так
історичні процеси відбуваються довго
тривало ну щось може від якось без нашої
участі якось
налагодитися тепер ми розуміємо що треба
руку на пульсі тримати постійно І щодня
тепер ми точно знаємо що переворот в
країні можна здійснити не лише за лічені
дні А за лічені години і те що ми маємо
діяти на
випередження ми маємо бути постійно в
такі високому тонусі нашої уваги це і
має означати Нашу З вами
відповідальність за сьогоднішній день і
відповідальність за наших дітей і наших
внуків ви знаєте я не можу сьогодні
просто не надати хоч кілька слів
Олександру Бо чесно вам скажу дивлячись
на нашу молодь розумну прогресивну
молодь яка хоче навчатися в наших вузах
і ви знаєте коли моя донька вступала і
ми думали про те куди їхати вчитися за
кордон чи в Україну Мені вона сказала
мама я не хочу будь- оди аби за кордоном
Я хочу в найкращий вуст але в Україні
Слава Україні Героям слава
Олександр Вітаю вас друзі так як вже
правильно сказали Я є студентом
київо-могилянської академії але ще рік
тому я закінчував школу і рік тому я
складав ЗНО так ось друзі в програмі ЗНО
є така чудова авторка яка також є
фактично серцем української ратури це
Ліна Костенко і я хочу сказати одну її
дуже важливу цитату яка сьогодні
надзвичайно актуальна нації вмирають не
від інфаркту спочатку їм забирає мову і
ви знаєте
друзі Сьогодні ми воюємо на двох фронтах
один із них це Донбас наші хлопці воюють
на сході і наші хлопці гинуть за те щоб
ми ми тут могли стояти під цим небом
могли посміхатись одне одному гуляти
парком розмовляти українською будувати
кар'єру навчатись в університеті але є
ще інший фронт і цей фронт друзі
відбувається Просто тут і просто зараз в
голові кожного з нас і Мова - це головна
зброя нас на цьому
фронті
справа і проблема не в російській мові
Росії не потрібна російськомовна Україна
Росії потрібна знищена Україна їй не
потрібна жодна Україна і ми маємо чинити
цьому опір і те Якою мовою Ми
розмовляємо Якою мовою читаємо книжки
Якою мовою здобуваємо освіту це є наша
атака на агресора це є наш захист і
знаєте що я ще хочу
сказати оці московські чорти незалежно
під якими прапорами зеленими чи
біло-синіми вони кажуть що Вони
захищають російськомовних українців та
друзі Я є російськомовним українцем я
виріс в російськомовній родині але я
громадянин України вдома я можу
спілкуватись якою завгодно мовою але є
державна мова Я розумію що це таке і я
шаную її і я вимагаю щоб державна мова
була державною і я вимагаю щоб люди для
яких Україна не вартує нічого не чіпляли
українську мову і коли Отакі пани
вибачте за слово пани хочуть переглянути
закон про мову можу їм лише порадити
перегляньте місце роботи А краще країну
проживання
Дякую та як допоможемо нашим студентам
правильно нашій молоді забезпечимо їм
нормальне життя в Україні і нормальну
освіту українською мовою правда ж ви
знаєте
кілька років тому я написала пісню хочу
лише приспів щоб ви мені допомогли Якщо
ти хочеш жити живи як знаєш що робити
Роби кохаєш
донестями кохай А Віри в мене не забирай
бо я знаю я хочу і буду йти бо я знаю я
хочу і буду йти бо я знаю я хочу і буду
йти до мети і разом Якщо ти хочеш жити
живи як знаєш що робити робити кохаєш
добесями кохає а віри в мене не забирай
бо я знаю я хочу і буду йти до мети і ми
йдемо до мети щодня Неважливо чи на
сцені чи тут в рядах Ми всі з вами
сьогодні в рядах в рядах на одному
фронті на захисті нашої країни і нашої
мови Спасибі Друзі за вашу присутність
за вашу небайдужість в першу чергу це і
є персональна відповідальність Слава
Україні Героям
слава їм заважає Наша мова і заважає
давно в
1729 році Петро Пей наказав переписати з
української на московською всі державні
постанови розпорядження в
1832 все навчання запровадилося на
Московській мові в
1863 сумнозвістний ївський циркуляр в
якому заборонили літературу українською
мовою в 64-му заборонили початкову школу
української мови в
1876 Емський указ в якому заборонили і
друкування і ввіс книжок українською
мовою але це не тільки 19 століття і в
20му в 33 році телеграма Сталіна про
припинення українізації 70-му про
заборону дисертації і науки української
мови а навіть в
1984 було заборонено підвищувати
зарплати вчителям української а вчителям
Московської підвищили на
15%. все робили щоб української мови не
було Але були ті хто українську мову
захищали зокрема правовими засобами
запрошую до слова
правозахисника громадського діяча і
дисиден
Слава Україні Героям
слава 30 років тому
ще навіть до набуття
Незалежності я знаходився у
Чернівцях після звільнення з колонії
суворого режиму і там в Чернівцях ми
готували одну з перших єврейських шкіл в
Україні і вже тоді стояло питання А на
якій мові повинно бути ця
освіта Якою мовою треба викладати
єврейські
предмети і в мене багато хто запитував
тоді як ви
думаєте через 50 років Якою мовою будуть
розмовляти євреї України івритом чи
ідишем і я
пройшовши
в'язниці і табори пройшовши членство
українській гельснській групі без
сумніву говорив
українською Бо я знав вже тоді що іншої
мови державної в Україні бути не може Бо
я тоді вже знав що в усіх
країнах національні меншини зокрема
євреї розмовляють місцевими мовами
англійською французькою польською і
іншими нас не ма іншого шляху крім цього
Але чому ж через 30 років Це питання Так
саме актуальне Ну може трохи менше ніж
тоді 30 років тому як і тоді чому так
тяжко ми
суваємося на шляху оволодіння всією
країною всіми громадянами українською
мовою тому що є потужний опір є потужний
опір збоку
Російської
Федерації яка розуміє що чим більше в
Україні української мови тим менше
можливості Росії повернути нас у
неоімперську
Росію але крім Росії є ще п'ята колона
проросійські сили в самій Україні які
також хотіли би позбавити нас
української мовою і ми про це все знаємо
але ми не мало думаємо про те що опором
також
є наша колоніальна ментальність
ми самі не дуже сміливі в просуванні
своєї української мови і це наша
проблема і нам треба її
позбавлятися Я думаю що добре Е рух
опору капітуляції Я представляю його
стратегічну
Раду висловив це в образі багатомірної
гібридної
капітуляції відступ іде по різних
напрямах і в
воєнному напряму і в
зовнішньополітичному і в економічному
але для нас важливоще можливо це в
гуманітарному і це не тільки питання
мови де зараз розглядається яке в
Верховній Раді цеє питання історії
Питання культури в всіх гуманітарних
напрямах іде капітуляція і поцін
напрямом
також коли ми
чому ось ці депутати які зараз там так
хочуть відмінити українську
мову я вже сказав частково про це але
крім того вони не виборювали разом з
нами незалежність України вони не стояли
з нами на майданах не захищали мову і
українську культуру вони не були на
фронті не захищали Україну проти Росії
що з них
питати їх треба міняти просто і чим
скоріше тим
краще Влада Влада має дуже коротку
пам'ять Вони можливо взагалі цього не
знала можливо бо вони молоді чи забули
про те що одної з важливих причин
Революції гідності Майдану 1314 років Це
було якраз національна
зрада національна зрада яка полягала не
тільки в харківських
угодах коли підписали з Росією і
продовжили на 25 років перебування
чорноморського флоту в Севастополі Але і
в сумнозвісному законі Ківалова
колісниченка який
обмежив українську мову де в Україні
обмежив українську мову і треба було
тільки перемогти на революції гідності
для того щоб повернути цю мову нам
назад Влада не пам'ятає що ця боротьба
за мову тоді під час Революції гідності
що це було причиною одною з основних
причин Майдану Революції гідності тобто
сьогодні відміняючи українську мову вони
роблять самі крок до Майдану наступного
до наступної революції яке їх не залиши
в цій
залі мова є одним основних чинників
ідентичності є і інші і культура і
історія і інші але без мови не можуть
суватися Ані культури Ані історія
також тому те що зараз робиться це
Реванш це з намагання реваншу і з боку
Росії і з боку проросійських сил не
пройде Реванш не пройде і капітуляція не
пройде Слава
Україні як писав володимирсюра о Місячне
сяйво і спів солов'я півонії Мальви
жоржини моря бриліантів це мова моя це
мова моєї Вкраїни яка у ній сила і кличе
і Сія яка в ній молоді ялини в натхнення
хвилини О Мово моя душа голосна України
ти сурми на сонці ти стягів Гаї ти
вибухів огнених повна Це матері мова я
звуки твої люблю наче очі дитини омова в
країни Хто любить її той любить мою
Україну І зараз я маю приємність
запросити на сцену моїх колег
колегдепутатів які точно мають що
сказати народна депутатка України
Вікторія
Сюмар Привіт всім друзі люблю вас всіх
тут наша чудова Софія розказувала
історію про українську мову Як довго її
знищували але давайте згадаємо нашу
недавную історію Моя дочка народилася в
році Знаєте яка була найбільша проблема
знайти мультик Король Лев українською
мовою
2003 рік це який рік української
незалежності ви знаєте де ми шукали
книжки українською мовою дитячі книжки
ми їздили у Львів щоб їх там купити бо у
Києві їх не було і ми своїх дітей не
могли навчати читати казки
українською Ми дивилися телебачення яке
телебачення ми дивилися друзі Ми
дивилися російське телебачення ви це
добре знаєте А якщо дивилися ніби
українське то завжди російською мовою і
знімали російські серіали і от в
2013 році ми зразу зрозуміли що таке
мова бо російські танки зайшли саме туди
де говорили російською і де вірили
російським телеканалам Що ми зробили ми
це вся та команда європейської
солідарності яка сьогодні тут перед вами
ми заборонили російські телеканали це
було правильно колеги чи ні
правильно нам стало гірше без російських
телеканалів Ми нарешті творимо
Український інформаційний простір Да у
нас багато гібридів ці гібриди сидять в
цьому залі і заце російські гроші
плодять російські телеканали але і цього
ми
позбудемося ми ввели квоту російської
мови
25% вони розказують що ми права там
порушуємо чиїсь Та в нас століттями наші
з вами права порушували коли дітей не
дозволяли вчити
українською зараз в нас на телебаченні
говорять українською мовою це правильно
чи
ні Ми зробили закони які дозволили в
Україні знімати українське кіно і ми
побачили українських кіборгів
українською мовою і українську армію
українською мовою це правильно чи
ні врешті-решт вони нам казали та що там
ваші Ні Та це ж якась
шароварщина і ви вводите квоти на радіо
та не буде в нас тільки українських
пісень
35% українських пісень кошмар жах ми
ввели квоти Ви знаєте скільки зараз на
українському радіо українських пісень
60% А на деяких радіостанціях
100 це правильно чи ні
ви знаєте про що все це говорить нам
століттями нав'язують комплекс
меншовартості нам кажуть ви українські
українці не спроможні писати свою
літературу знімати свої фільми нам
розказують ви не вмієте писати пісні і
співати а можете переспівувати там щось
тільки російську попсу але за ці роки
всього лише за пть років
ми показали всім Та ми крутіше росіян
розумієте наша культура сьогодні частина
європейської культури наші пісні в топі
світових
рейтингів ми можемо і ми це сказали Нам
сьогодні знову оці хлопці тут розказують
що українська мова - це ніщо і це
дискримінація насправді ніщо це вони і
ми їм про це скажемо нас багато і нас не
подолати ви не знищите українську мову
бо коли вмирає мова і розстрілюють мову
вмирають держава Україна Житиме Слава
Україні
[оплески]
Слава запрошую мою колегу народна
депутатка України фракція голос Соломія
Бобровська
Дай Боже дякую всім містам Які сюди
приїхали я дякую всім друзям які з моїм
поколінням уже в 12-му році виходили і
тут біля Верховної Ради і там Біля
Українського дому і голодували я
пам'ятаю як ми там місяцями жили і тут є
петрошкутяк він точно Десь тут є який
один з тих хто голодував а потім поїхав
першим з добровольцями на Схід і мені
дуже я пишаюся цим і ви знаєте те
сьогодні вже як депутатка дев'ятого
скликання я насправді безмежно вдячна це
були Мої перші слова напевно і по думки
всіх всім депутатам восьмого скликання
які мали сміливість і відвагу прийняти
цей закон я більш ніж переконана що
навіть з цими законопроектами які подає
божанський і не лише він насправді в
Раду напевно ми би нас не стало би сили
цього зробити і нас було би меншість щоб
перебити ідеологічно все ж таки прийняти
закон про держав українську мову як
державну я дякую тим хто мав мужність і
відвагу це зробити в восьмому скликанні
сказати що справді Ми Українці - це наше
право я би звідси ще хотіла Подякувати І
безкоштовним курсам української мови Я
знаю що Точно вони тут є І це сотні
людей викладачів а ще більше тисячі
людей волонтерів які прийшли не
посоромилися вчитися українською від від
Волині до Луганської області від
Херсонщини до Чернігівщини я знаю це моя
улюблена фраза як людина з
Дніпропетровщини До речі звідки е сам
бужанський Який його розказує нам про
дискримінацію і сказала Прекрасну фразу
яка сьогодні в багатьох є на футболках
коли ми говоримо українською то кожне
слово за кожним словом падає цеглина з
Кремля пора цій цеглі впасти пора їй
згоріти щоб ніяка сволота не мала права
сказати що ми приходимо захищати тут
свій язик ідіть своїми язиками за свої
перебрики не треба нам ніяких проектів
наша країна велика неподільна Ми чекаємо
Крим додому Ми чекаємо Луганщину додому
донеччину додому і не вздумайте до нас
більше жодним своїм кірзовим чободом
вступати я переконана ще в п'ятницю коли
стане питання про цю про законопроект в
нас точно буде такий самий рух і двіж як
тут на вулиці і ми нікому не дамо
натиснути кнопку зелену і підтримати
законопроект бержанської ганьба їм Дякую
вам До зустрічі ще вранці завтра 9:30 не
забувайте нам треба дотиснути їх щоб Ні
щоб в цьому скликанні ці законопроекти
не стояли більше по денному Дякую Слава
Україні геро
Слава маю приємність запросити свого
колегу який буквально вчора написав
запит до потерпілого щоби той уточнив
яка це та сторона напала на українську
державу народний депутат України
Володимир
арієв Слава Україні
ро
сла друзі я виріс в Києві а значить я
виріс в
російськомовному
середовищі і перехід на українську мову
був моїм абсолютно усвідомленим кроком
це сталося тоді ко коли розвалювався
Радянський Союз коли піднімалася
національна свідомість українців коли
Народний рух України робив мітин
коли повставала українська
нація у 90му році коли
відбувалося Студентське голодування ми
зі своїми друзями зі школи вішали на
нашому ліцеї синьо-жовтий прапор і я
тоді
відчув як в російськомовному середовищі
бути
україномовним це було важко
це було
незрозуміло але я кожному сьогодні хто
говорить російською і боїться переходити
на українську хочу навести свій приклад
це не страшно вивчити нарешті українську
мову і почати нею
говорити я категорично не сприймав
будь-які нападки коли говорили що це
мова селюків і так далі що Що ти говориш
цією мовою незрозуміло говори на
общепонятно я тоді У мене як і у всіх
тих
хто поважає і любить українську
наростала відчуття
протесту Колись я не витримав і у
відповідь на чергове приниження
української мови достатньо жорстко
відповів І після того мене Партія
Регіонів
полоскала дуже довго і навіть намагалися
відкривати проти мене кримінальні
справи У 2014 році ми вийшли на Майдан
Незалежності і в тому числі за захист
гідності гідністі права говорити своєю
мовою Ми правильно ж зробили тоді і ми
тоді уже розуміли що Мова
це для нас серце і душа це фундамент для
України це те що відрізняє нас від
руского мира і кожного хто говорить
українською це відрізняє від русского
мира і Чим більше ми будемо говорити
українською тим більше ця про це
провалля між окупантами і вільним світом
буде збільшуватися і ми зобов'язані
збільшити це провання Різ з крокодилами
І тільки так правильно так
тому я нещодавно коли побачив що
журналістка прямого
каналу Наталка фісич Моя дружина
абсолютно чітко заявила у відповідь на
те як зневажливо поставилась до
української мови і дуже ввічливо але
юридично бездоганно зробила всі речі і
змусила тих хто це робив вибачатися І
навіть ту компанію
яка яка в якій відбулася ця історія
вибачатися публічно то це приклад для
кожного із вас не проходьте бовз цьо
ніколи не Не давайте можливості
зневажати українську завжди ставайте на
її захист тому що це буде успіх і закон
про українську мову дає вам цю зброю
захищайте себе захищайте свою гідність
захищайте своє право говорити
українською тому що іншої України у нас
немає Ви згодні з цим
так тому ніколи не соромтеся ніколи не
проходьте пост не кажіть що можливо це
не моя справа Будьте пильними будьте
вільними і будьте
абсолютно чітко а з усіх сторін сильними
тому що сьогодні право на нашій
стороні
спроба виключити українську з
освіти говорити Сьогодні про те що треба
забезпечити права
руськоязичних на освіту натикається на
один залізобетонний
аргумент в Росії сьогодні
мешкає 5 млн
українців скільки україномовних шкіл
перебуває сьогодні в Російській
Федерації ну нуль то чому ми сьогодні не
маємо напра на за правилом міжнародним
правилом паритету зробити те саме І це
право українців право українців
навчатися українською мовою говорити
українською мовою і мати повагу до своєї
національної ідентичності коли ми чужу
ідентичність
не чіпаємо і не руйнуємо і сьогодні всі
хто зібралися тут мають чітко усвідомити
і нести це своїм друзям сусідам що наша
боротьба в попереду і ми маємо зробити
все для того щоб українську мову
сьогодні поважали а завтра до неї
ставилися як до явищ яке абсолютно
нормальне в Україні і жодних питань щодо
використання української мови в Україні
на більше не виникало тому що це
природньо це нормально і ми можемо це
зробити правда Так ми зробимо Це
обов'язково Я хочу щоб ми зарядилися
зараз тим духом які сьогодні панує тут
Коли прийшли сьогодні люди небайдужі
Коли прийшли сьогодні люди активні
давайте далі захищати мову від будь-яких
нападок і Давайте робити її такою
яка стане повсякденним для нашого життя
бо вона цього заслужила цього року мав
мало відбутися відбувається 200 років
300 років з того моменту як Петро пе
підписав перший наказ про те що
забороняється книговидання українською
досить більше цього не буде і на останок
я хочу сказати ми сьогодні забралися тут
щоб мову нам не відібрали злі
язики і зробимо їх разом
бужениною Слава
Україні ну Володимир арєва як завжди з
бужениною це звичайно жорстко але
напевно на це заслужили і заслужили
особливо оті депутатики які отут зараз
була перерва вони отак пробігли забігли
пробігли забігли а я ж то розумію що
добрих 73% українців голосували за
певних конкретних депутатів Я думаю
зараз дуже гарний час тих депутатів які
не заявили про конкретну позицію брати і
добре копати що в Україні має бути
українська мова українське навчання і ці
депутати як справжні слуги народу от ще
одна біжить
мають підтримувати те чого вимагають
українці і сьогодні ми тут вимагаємо
захистити українську мову захистити
українську мову захистити українську
мову захистити українську мову захистити
українську мову Ну якщо йдеться про
захист то Я запрошую свою колегу яку
наші Захисники називають просто ветмама
очільниця Міністерства у справах
ветеранів попередніх пть років моя
колега народний депутат Ірина
фріс Слава
Україні Слава дивіться в мене до вас
одне прохання Подивіться навколо
Подивіться один на одного ми всі
українці і ми цим пишаємось А головне ми
маємо пам'ятати про тих українців про
тих героїв які зараз тримають небо над
нами я прошу вшанувати хвилиною мовчання
всіх героїв які сьомий рік боронять нашу
незалежність і наш
суверенітет
дякую дякую воно того варте і Ми завжди
будемо пам'ятати кожного кожного Хто
віддав найдорожче за цю державу за її
незалежність За українську мову за наш
суверенітет кожного тому що заради них і
Завдяки ним Ми сьогодні є ви знаєте Ось
там є люди які на намагаються забрати в
нас те що нас об'єднує забрати в нас те
що є нашим забрати майбутнє нашої
держави Тому що українська мова є одним
зі стовпів нашої Незалежності ось ці
слуги не знаю якого народу не хочу
навіть вимовляти якого вони прислужники
Кремля насправді але ми вибвимом цю
помилку нам говорять про те що Какая
разница адже на вартість горілки чи
вартість ковбаси мова не впливає
говорять вони а втім я хочу сказати що
мова має значення коли окупант скомандує
по
вагонам так вже було в нашій державі і в
Україні в 30-ті так було коли наче скот
нквд пакував по вагонах кримських
Татарів в 1943 році так було коли
росіяни виганяли з власних домівок
вірмен інгушеів чеченців поляків Ми
пам'ятаємо що окупант і агресор який
приходить спочатку відбирає мову а потім
забирає ваш будинок і ми будемо боронити
і
захищати мову армію Віру нашу не
залежність і нашу
державу друзі коли країна приймає мову
окупанта а це те що нам каже пан
бужанський стосовно
освіти Ця країна
капітулює або втрачає незалежність ми не
дамо нас втягнути в повзучу капітуляцію
та в махровий Реванш тому що ми знаємо
За що ми стоїмо І що ми боронимо тому що
Ми віримо в те що ми робимо тому що нам
є що передати нашим дітям які будуть
жити у вільній суверенній незалежній
державі
друзі Сьогодні ми маємо владу
колаборантів владу колаборантів яка
намагається на з тихим сапом завести в
стойло Російське стойло де вже давно
перебувають росіяни які втратили честь
гідність право на свободу право на
зібрання право на обрання майбутнього
вони втратили все Але ми з вами українці
ми боронимо все що є українським і
сповідуємо українське тому що воно
надихає нас тому що Ми нащадки козаків
тому що Ми нащадки тих хто боронив цю
державу під прапорами
УНР
УПА під прапорами незалежної України
тому що вони боролись за цю
державу сповідуючи її як українці будучи
українцями Будьмо достойними тих
нащадками кого ми з вами
є я хочу вас закликати
друзі свідомо відноситися до того що ці
люди які намагаються нам розповідати
Якою мовою мають вчитись наші з вами
діти вони між собою відверто зухвало
дуже голосно в залі парламенту говорять
руским матом і цим людям Ми дамо
можливість говорити нам в який спосіб
спілкуватися один з одним друзі Мова -
це наша незалежність Мова - це наша
незалежність і ми маємо її боронити тому
що той хто не спроможний вивчити
українську
насправді не хоче її вчити через
комплекс
мешовартості тому що Українську буде не
буде вчити лише той хто є малоросом той
хто хоче ве вернути сюди малоросію Ми не
маємо права відступати і дамо відсіч
кожному обранцю навіть якщо його обрана
за те що він намагається зруйнувати або
навіть поставити під сумнів право нашої
української мови бути державною Уявіть
собі щоб у Франції або в
США викладали в школах англійської
замість англійської німецької чи нською
це нонсенс тому що Держава починається з
мови тому що українська мова - це наше
надбання яке ми маємо захищати і будемо
захищати І наостанок ви
знаєте ми з вами зараз маємо можливість
дуже добре бачити тих гнит Як казав
Симон Петлюра які страшніші за
московських Шей вони зараз там як Агенти
Кремля проводять політику росифіка
нашої держави Але ми з вами здатні
задавити цих гнид так само всередині як
роблять це наші Захисники на східному
фронті не дамо жодного шансу зруйнувати
підірвати чи підставити навіть під
сумнів нашу українську мову бо вона є
державна і вона є єдина Слава
Україні Слава Слава Нації
Смерть Україна понад усе Я не втримаюсь
Путін
земля А ви знали що Іра з
Криму тому вона особливо заслуговує
подяки і підтримку за свою
[оплески]
позицію що ж Але перед тим як
запросити на сцену наступну неймовірну
людину треба стати для початку
струнку втягнути
животи
мобілізуватися і бути готовими до наказу
наказу захищати Україну герой
України народний депутат
України нещодавно він ще був
командувачем десантно-штурмових військ
України генерал-лейтенант Забродський
шановні
друзі перш за все Я хочу поправити нашу
шановну ведучу ми всі мобілізовані якщо
ми стоїмо тут значить нам не байдуже
Якщо нам не байдуже Значить ми готові до
дії якщо ми готові до дій то у них
нічого не вийде будеду намагатися бути
по війзковому крафта насправді Моя
історія дуже проста
я народився і виріс в традиційно
російськомовному регіоні Я маю на увазі
славетну дніпропетровщину і я вітаю
своїх земляків які зараз присутні теж на
цьому
[оплески]
мітингу Я ніколи не чув щоб так зване
мовне питання було перешкодою за всі
роки нашої Незалежності наприклад для
південного машино ного заводу обкб
південне щоб славити ю
державу щоб заробляти для неї додаткові
очки на міжнародній арені жорстко
конкурувати і розвивати нашу
промисловість Я не вірю що це питання
постало в 14-му році на це питання
дпропетровщина теж відповіла вона
відповіла 2 тисячами військовослужбовців
які були призвані і гідно виконували
свой військовий
обов'язок я не пам'ятаю що від
використання російської мови приклад
десь у когось в бою заклинив автомат не
пам'ятаю щоб відмовив двигун бойової
машини Зато я пам'ятаю людей які
віддавали життя за цю
країну і останніми словами були слова на
російській і це краща відповідь на так
званий мовний
вопрос його нема В Україні має бути лише
одна Мова українська і ніхто не зазихає
на право спілкуватися тою мовою Яку
кожен з нас вважає за рідно
На жаль зовсім інший погляд на це
питання У кремлевських стратегів
гібридної війни І сьогодні вони можуть
пишатися сьогодні у них успіх на сомому
році війни посеред української столиці
под стінами українського парламенту
українці намагаються захистити
українську
мову але дякуючи нашим з вами
зусиллями жали що їхня радість буде дуже
і дуже
недовга тому що ми добре пам'ятаємо що з
мови починається потім послімови
з'являється колорадська стрічка після
цього розмова про те що потрібно
захищати рускоязичних
Хоча я як рускоязичний ніякої до захисту
не потребую після цього з'являються
Гради і після цього на адміністративних
будівлях з'являються інші
прапори
насправді мовне питання Воно дуже
чутливе і тундітне і це вірне воно
подвійно вірно коли мова йде про наше
майбутнє про наших школярів і студентів
про нашу освіту ті які закладають
фундамент для майбутнього існування нас
як держави ті хто завтра стануть
бізнесменами артистами
дипломатами вченими військовими медиками
і таке інше тому тут ми подвійно з вами
не маємо права на будь-яку помилку і
однозначно поно щоб збереглись
відповідні норми закону стосовно мовної
квоти в освіті і ніяк інакше ми не дамо
їм цього шансу реалізувати черговий
досить таки примітивний але дуже
резонансний запит на черговий
Реванш наші діти наше майбутнє майбутнє
у нас одне європейське Країна У нас одна
Україна і мова має бути однею
українською
Ми не маємо права
скибити якщо ми це зробимо
ні Наша історія ні наша сьогодення нам
цього не пробачуть
дякую одна єдина Соборна Україна одна
єдина Соборна Україна одна єдина
своборна Україна одна єдина свободна
Україна А ще Україну єднає пісня Я
пам'ятаю як на початку 90х коли мене ще
в багатьох областях обзивали малою
бандерівкою бо я приїхала зі Львова і
говорила українською був один гурт який
дав дорогу в
80-х90-х роках українкі пісні і сьогодні
з нами фронтмен гурту рутенія Анатолій
[музика]
Сухий
Слава Україні
Слава я
руг чорний сотник УПА моя сотня далекому
схроні добрі хлопці в моєму
загоні ідуть завтра в бі
Ти не чекай моя
додому з лісу
партизана по
Завтра знову буде
бій і
не вернеться Сотник твій я кру і мені
все одно мені славу співаю
Круга відрізняю від ворога
друга я Круг чорний Галицький Круг Ти не
чекай бо я
Оксано
додому з лісу
партизана по
Завтра
знову буде пі і
не вернеться Сотник дві А
пам'ятаєш друже кара
як глушили ми рибу в
Дністрі пам'ятаєш той місяць тій
зорі друже карася ми ще живі А
[музика]
пам'ятаєш друже калино в 33м свою
Полтавщину пам'ятаєш той хліба
кусок друже калино ми ще
живі Ти не чекай моя
озано
додому з лісу
партизана бо
завтра знову буде біла і
не вернеться Сотник ві я
рук чорний сотник УПА я
гадюркуною ту душу
я гранату до серця
прив'яжу Хай спасе мою душу
Ти не чекай моя
Оксано
додому з лісу
партизана бо
завтра знову буде бій і
не вернеться
твій Слава
Україні Слава Я вірю що скоро настане
такий час що питання мовою взагалі не
буде стояти я вірю в те що всі
українські сили у всьому світі
об'єднаються ми збудуємо державу яка
буде
національною українською Яка займе
достойне місце серед всіх націй світу на
сві просто
дякую
дякуємо дякуємо Анатолію сухому Дякуємо
за мою улюблену пісню як рук чорний
сотник УПА це одна з тих павстанських
пісень які Я вивчила найпершіше але ви
знаєте я не дарма казала що з нами
українська громада усього світу мене
завжди дивували ті українці Які поїхавши
з України за різних обставин в
четвертому і в п'ятому поколіннях не те
що десь там захищають українську мову а
ще й вільно не нею говорять тому ми
сьогодні маємо також і послання від
українців Європи Я запрошую до слова
голову української Всесвітньої
координаційної ради Михайла
ратушного Дорогі співвітчизники в травні
Минулого року коли цим шляхом до
приміщення українського
парламенту пересувався
вже президент Зеленський і виступаючи В
цьому залі в інавгураційній доповіді він
сказав нас не 400 нас 65
мільйонів мають росифікації українців і
України проходять не лише по містах і
містечках нашої Батьківщини вони
проходять по всьому
світу європейська
європейській
європейська європейський конгрес
Українців на чолі з головою об'єднання
українців
Чехії Василем райчинцем світовий конгрес
Українців начолі з Павлом грудою з
Канади об'єднання українців в Австралії
написали звернення заяви до того ж
Зеленського до того ж Міністра
закордонних справ до голови Верховної
Ради не допустити прийняття чергового
антиукраїнського закону ми не допустимо
цього щоб цей законопроект був прийнятий
цих 65 млнв українців на яких посилався
Зеленський в травні Минулого року не
хочуть і не допустять щоб їх знову
русифіковували це голос
українців
і в Україні і за кордоном Я вийшов на цю
трибуну щоб сказати Бо знаю що є стрім
що нас дивляться представники
української
діаспори трудових мігрантів по всьому
світу Ми чуємо вас ми знаємо що ви з
нами Просимо Вас звертайтеся до вищого
керівництва держави Щоб вони
припинили прийняття розгляду і
голосування за цей законопроект який
внесений депутатом Бужанська я звертаюся
до кожного вас прийти не лише сьогодні
бо вони сьогодні ми ще не перемо могли
вони відтягнули перенесли прийняття
цього закону на завтра надіючись що нас
завтра тут не буде не буде Цього
громадського тиску якого вони бояться
якого вони не очікували як пять чи шість
років тому с років тому не очікували тут
регіонали вони вже казали українці хахли
не поднимуться Майдану більше не буде
вони цинічно сміялися виходячи сюда але
появився Майдан це має бути великим
застереженням до тих хто сидить сьогодні
в парламенті для президента Зеленського
для різних
бужинських що це може їх
Винести з цих владних камінетів тому що
ми українці довго запрягаємо але коли ми
вже сіідлаємо своїх коней то ті хто
стоять проти нас опиняються або на
смітнику історії або в Ростові Слава вам
і слава
[оплески]
Україні мова кожного народу неповторна і
своя в ній гремлять громи в негоду в
тиші трелі солов'я на своїй природній
мові і потоки гомонять зеленклени у
дібро по кленовому шумлять солов'їну
барвінкову колосисту навіки українську
рідну мову дали в дар мені батьки
берегти її плекати буду всюди й
повсякчас бож єдина Так як мати мова в
кожного із нас і саме тому що в украї по
всьому світу кожна нація Кожен народ має
свою мову тому по цілому світу ми як у
українці маємо мати можливість нести
представляти вчити і знайомити усіх саме
з українською мовою тому Я запрошую до
слова телеведучого громадського діяча
але поза тим мегавідомого мандрівника
Ігоря
[музика]
захаренка Слава Україні Героям слава
мова дійсно знає мова дійсно має
значення Мова - це сила держави знаєте я
коли подорожую світом і спілкуюся з
іноземцями доводиться пояснювати що ми
не росіяни Ми різні країни у нас різні
мови і всі дуже дивуються Як ви у вас
інша мова так кажемо в нас інша мова У
нас інша історія у нас інша культура
інші страви і борж - це українська
страва не російська і доводиться
доводиться пояс
і розповідати про нашу історію і
розповідати про війну яка триває на
сході про війну за голови про за про
війну за культурну спадщину Адже у нас і
історію теж хочуть забрати і забирають
так війна триває і війна не тільки на
сході війна економічна війна
інформаційна і війна за мову і ми
повинні розуміти що війна за мову це не
менш важливо Да й захищати мову це не
менш важливо ніж захищати наші кордони і
якщо ми тут не переможемо ми можемо і не
вижити але ми вижимо ми виживемо ми
переможемо Тому що ми тут Тому що ми на
захисті нашої мови тому що ми на захисті
майбутнього нашої країни Ми
переможемо солітарни
приблизно рік тому ми закріпили в
Конституції України вектор розвитку
Української держави на євро і
євроатлантичну інтеграцію з одного боку
це є закріплення статусу України як
держави Яку мають чути бо ми є
самодостатня держава з іншого боку це є
питання нашої безпеки бо будучи у гроні
європейських держав маючи за собою щит
НАТО Ми Точно зможемо агресора давати в
зуби і тому агресор так біситься і тому
агресор насилає своїх недолютків та іншу
нечість щоб так бити українську армію
українську Віру українську мову А чи ви
знаєте хто саме Зробив те найбільше
напевно зробив щоб у нас було закріплено
вектор розвитку євро і євроатлантичний
це моя колега народна депутатка Українки
А ще рік тому воно було
віце-прем'єр-міністром з питань євро
євроатлантичної інтеграції неймовірна
Іванна
клипушнсадзе Дуже дякую Софія Дорогі
українці дорогі друзі дорогі патріоти
хто сьогодні прийшов сюди
висловити свій свою позицію свій протест
проти того нахабства яке хоче робити
менобільшість Я хочу почати з рядків
Ліни
Костенко шматок землі ти
звешся Україною ти був до нас і будеш
після нас мій
предковічний мій умитий
росами Космічний вічний зоряний
барвінковий коли ти навіть звався
малоросія твоя поетеса була українкою і
так це про Лесю
Українку
попри свою страшну хворобу вона писала і
для
своїх для тих людей які жили одночасно з
нею і для нас для того щоби надихати нас
писала українською і ми з вами точно не
лежачі яких хтось хоче бити як хочуть
щоби ми були лежачими і Путін і
Зеленський Я вважаю що всі ці реваншисти
які на намагаються Сьогодні знову живу
мову гордого і гідного народу якось
затюкати вони просто смішні і в цьому
наша сила пописала Леся Українка щоб не
плакати я сміялась і я вважаю що ці
прикрі непорозуміння у кріслах народних
депутатів ці народні депутати від
молобільшості які хочуть руйнувати мову
вони смішні ми з вами в цьому теж маємо
силу їм не вдасться зруйнувати мову тому
що це те саме що заборонити схід сонця
ми вже перемогли а вони вже програли
Чому Тому що ми протягом останніх п'яти
років ми зуміли ухвалити закон про
державну мову ми зуміли ухвалити закон
про освіту в якому ми відвели належне
місце
державній мові ми зуміли з вами разом
довести що всі ті кпини стосовно того
стосовно провінційності української мови
нас більше не бентежать бо ми довели що
на українські кінофільми ходять мільйони
глядачів вони програли тоді коли світ
почав нарешті писати Київ а не Київ а
вони хочуть сьогодні повернути нас на 30
років тому коли тут у цій будівлі
звучали промови на
общепонятном їм цього не вдасться і не
вдасться Саме через те що ми з вами
стоїмо разом на захисті держави бо Мова
- це основа нашої держави бо Мова - це
один із стрижнів за рахунок яких наш
голос у світі чути і ми знаємо що цей
голос поту
Українці протягом війни під час проти
російської федерації доволи що вони
спроможні боронити свою землю Але ми
також спроможні боронити свою мову ми з
вами
ще на жаль через 30 років після того як
у цій залі була проголошена Декларація
про державний суверенітет і далі
мусимо відстоювати своє право в
Україні навчатися мріяти співати вірити
боротися українською мовою але ми таки
обов'язково відстоїмо це
право і в нас з вами є така можливість
тому що ми тримаємося разом тому що
різні політичні сили яким небайдужа
Україна стоїть разом я хочу подякувати
кожному з вас кожному хто прийшов і
виступив на захист мови Нам казали
пригадуєте ЄС не намажеш на хліб НАТО не
намажеш на хліб мову не намажеш на хліб
може її на хліб і не намажеш але мову
кусають але хліб кусають зубами А якщо
цими зубами захочуть знищити нашу мову
то ми ці Зу
спільно повеламуємо Слава
Україні ви бачите які в нас бойові жінки
чоловіки і то так м'якше кажуть А жінки
кажуть за мову дамо пописку за мову зуби
повиламуємо жінка - це Берегиня жінка
має захищати своїх дітей свою родину а
оскільки нашою родиною є Україна то
мусимо захищати разом Українську Державу
і знаєте як написав колись відомий поет
Богдан
Стельмах промовлю Слово мати промовлю
слово син а потім ще два слова карлина і
журба могутня рідна мова народ водила
мій по мисленому древу від мурави до
хмар
рідна мово перше слово ти в устах моїх
плекала першу пісню
колискову наді мною
вознесла і як я в рідні
печальні про шипчу слова
прощальні
присягаю рідна мово будуть Це твої
слова оце рідна мова рідна колескова
рідна пісня Я розумію що добрій частині
нечисті яка сидить на жаль в парламенті
бо надурила українців рідною є якийсь
там язик але як то кажуть в Україні
українська мова і українцю набагато
краще буде житися якщо буде розмовляти
українською що ж а я маю нагоду
запросити сюди одного зі своїх добрих
побратимів Ви ж знаєте що я За освітою
політолог міжнародник хоча дехто в
парламенті каже от співачка прийшла щось
нам тут в парламенті вказує і я скажу
чесно У нас багато фантастичних
науковців справжніх політологів які
кожною своєю дниною кожною своєю
науковою працею з обороняють захищають
українську мову тому Я запрошую на слово
доброго друга політолога Сергій
Таран Слава
Україні Слава знаєте зараз дуже часто
кажуть що мовине питання слугам потрібно
лише для того щоб нас від чогось
відволікти кажуть що справді ми б краще
замість мовного питання мали б
обговорювати Чому український президент
зізнався в порушенні закону а жоден
квоохоронний орган не порушив проти
нього справи Справді ми зараз мали би з
вами обговорювати загострення на фронті
коли щодня гинуть наші воїни а президент
не наважується вголос назвати країну
агресора і соромливо прикривається
словом та
сторона Ми би з вами зараз мали
обговорювати провали у зовнішній
політиці Коли Україна після того як
пропрасювала європейський
євроатлантичний вектор зараз сходить на
менівці міжнародної політики ми з вами
зараз мали би обговорювати ті скандали
які щодня відбуваються у слух народу Але
про які телеканали воліють не говорити І
тому вони нам кидають це мовне питання
це все правда але правда те що мовне
питання для них набагато важливіше слуга
народу зараз дуже швидко втрачає рейтинг
а владу вони втрачати не хочуть і вони
зараз в стінах цьо парламенту готують
нову коаліцію слугами
Кремля вони зараз втрачають рейтинг і
Вони готуються прийти до влади у місцеві
органи влади восени по всій Україні
відбудуться місцеві вибори там цих
органах місцевої влади слуги народу
планують створити коаліцію з
прислужниками Путіна і для цього Їм
потрібне мовне питання для того щоб
показати їм що вони для них свої вони
створюють для нас
оце ганьбу яка називається що ми на
30-му році Незалежності маємо
відстоювати українську мову А тим часом
вони збирається зливати Україну і
створювати нову коаліцію слуги Кремля
тому що б сьогодні не було в цих цінах
парламенту ми маємо пам'ятати що
захищати українську мову Нам доведеться
ще довго дуже скоро Вибори відбудуться
по всій Україні і тому в кожній області
Ми маємо захистити українську мову і
привести до влади проєвропейські сили
особливо в тих областях де
прокремлівські глашатаї мріють створити
нові сепаратистські анклави українську
мову ми маємо захищати в кожному
містечку в кожному селі України де слуги
народу будуть в школах розказувати що
кака разница українську мову ми маємо
захищати в моєму рідному місті Києві де
слуги народу штовхають у владу тих хто
всій Україні показує що таке велюрові
закони
Я впевнений що ми Захистимо і українську
мову і українську державність тому що ми
готові виходити на вулицю ми будемо
завтра тут і ми будемо відстоювати наш
вибір українська мова була є і буде А
разом з нею буде І завжди буде Україна
Слава
Україні Слава
знаєте рік тому як відбулися вибори і
багато державницьки настроєних людей
почало дуже-дуже дуже переживати як же ж
воно далі буде бо одне слово обіцянки а
друге чи можуть люди здійснювати ті чи
інші обіцянки один
блогер один громадський діяч створив
групу українці
25 тож Я запрошую до слова засновника
цієї групи яка бореться за все
українське в Україні проти різної
нечесті яка сюди намагається активно
заповзати Андрій
смолінь Доброго дня Києве Доброго дня
Україно радий бачити що сьогодні ми всі
тут зібралися на площі Конституції
захистити нашу мову захистити нашу
країну захистити дійсно наш вибір
українського та європейського
майбутнього і надзвичайно важливо зараз
захистити саме українську мову тому що
Мова - це наш кордон Мова - це наш
ідеологічний бар'єр це захист від
руского мира який зараз намагається знов
повернутися в нашу державу знов
намагається очолити наші державні
інституції наші органи місцевого
самоврядування знов намагається захопити
наш інформаційний простір хіба можемо ми
зараз сьогодні на сьомому році війни
дозволити це Ні не можемо хіба можемо ми
зрештою зробити щось для того щоб
захистити нашу мову і для того щоб
зберегти мовний закон зберегти освітній
закон Так ми обов'язково це можемо
зробити і ми Обов'язково це зробимо тому
що Мова - це власне те що об'єднує а не
те що роз'єднує як говорять сьогодні
слуги народу і як говорять сьогодні
слуги Кремля Мова - це те що єднає
Україну І тому надзвичайно важливо що
сьогодні тут перед Верховною Радою
України в центрі нашої столиці
знаходяться люди які приїхали зі Львова
з Харкова з Одеси з Дніпра зрештою Кияни
які сьогодні тисячами підтримали власне
нашу акцію на підтримку єдиної державної
мови сьогодні дійсно вони хочуть забрати
нашу мову сьогодні вони хочуть зробити
все щоб знов повернути нас до дрімучої
тюрми народів Російської імперії ви
знаєте коли в перший раз було заборонено
московською державою українську мову Це
був далекий
1627 рік майже 400 років назад це був
перший раз і крайній раз останній раз це
відбувається прямо сьогодні коли ці люди
які прийшли влади сьогодні говорять На
жаль штампами Кремля і коли сьогодні
Вони намагаються знову русифікувати
освіту це є найгірше що могло б статися
в нашій державі це якщо ми втратимо нашу
українську мову і зараз дійсно Важливо
щоб ми в усіх наших містах в усіх
містечках в усіх селах зробили все щоб
захистити нашу мову і Я впевнений що ми
Обов'язково це зробимо вже за кілька
місяців і це буде власне маркер того
куди ми рухаємося і як ми захищаємо нашу
державу Мова - це не просто запис
Конституції це не просто закон Мова - це
Україна і в даному випадку ми захищаємо
Україну ми захищаємо наше майбутнє
майбутнє наших поколінь адже історія
твориться саме сьогодні саме Сьогодні ми
творимо те що буде в нашій державі через
10 років через 20 і навіть через сотні
років Саме тут сьогодні плекається
історія нашої держави і коли вони
говорять про Какая разница коли вони
говорять що мова неважлива то я хочу
сказати одну важливу річ мова важлива
мова має значення мова має значення мова
має значення мова має значення мова має
значення мова має значення Сьогодні має
значення мова має сьогодні українська
мова дійсно захищена проукраїнським
законом про мову проукраїнським законом
про освіту і ми з вами всі разом зробимо
все щоб в жодному випадку не не
нівелювати ці закони Ми зробимо все щоб
захистити українське законодавство яке
було прийняте в минулі роки тому що саме
воно є гарантом того щоб рухатися дійсно
до української та європейської України
слава Україні
слава Слава нації Смерть ворога Україна
понад усе Дякую вам що ви сьогодні
прийшли і я нагадаю що завтра о 9:30 ми
знову збираємося тут Тому що завтра вони
знову хочуть повертатися до питання
знищення української мови знищення
україномовної освіти будь ласка
приходьте тому що що Мова це важливо і
Україна - це важливо Дякую
[оплески]
вам Андрій абсолютно правий Ви знаєте це
ж якраз був мій комітет гуманітарної та
інформаційної політики де під час
карантину тричі пропихали на розгляд цей
законопроект Ми з моїми колегами
вятровичем і княжицьким казали ви ж
обіцяли що під час карантину дражливі
питання ставитися не будуть будемо
ставити лишень питання які мають
стосунок до протидії коронавірусній
хворобі а вони всі мовчки кивали
головами і три рази пропихали два рази
Ми трафили його відкласти відправити на
доопрацювання а в третій раз в нас якраз
змінився голова комітету так на хвильчку
один пішов міністр другий прийшов і тут
раптово вони голосують що виносять на
комітет і нібито голосування що що ми
проти але в зал законопроект все одно
направляється вже з понеділка разумков і
Корнієнко заявили що так ми ставимо в
четвер бо це питання
потрібне коли ми сказали фе вони раптово
підімгали хвостики і сказали що
ой-ойойойой може це не в четвер може
буде в п'ятницю Вони знали що Ми сюди
приїдемо Вони знали що ми будемо
протестувати і вони вирішили перенести
на п'ятницю щоби нас тут не було але ми
тут будемо правда правда Я ще прошу щоби
Кияни масово прийшли тому що можливо
хтось з регіонів змусить поїхати але
якщо вийде Київ то тоді ми точно
витримуємо нашу оборону тому що це з
одного боку оборона української мови а з
іншого боку це ж яка ж їм підстава вони
так старалися а в них нічого не має
вийти Ну і щоби було ще приємніше Я знаю
що гаряче що па сонце хто міг
переміститися в Тінь але зараз на цій
сцені буде ще гарячіше а гарячіше тому
що згадайте Майдан згадайте Майдан коли
горіло все коли палало а над майданом
звучало Ми
йдемо навколо гаснуть ліхтарі
мийдемо
попереду
вого і на сцену виходить наша улюблена
справжня народна Марічка Бурмака
українській мові своїх батьків ми
співаємо українською Я пишу пісні для
дітей українською тому що в цьому
майбутнє це те що нас єднає Рік тому був
прийнятий закон про мову ми всі
раділи щоби діти вчили в школах щоби
закон про мову Українська мова мала
належну підтримку на за ріні Що
відбувається зараз збираються внести
поправки в закон про мову як тільки
треба прикрити щось виноситься мовне
питання в нас що в країні все добре
Зараз у нас все добре на Донбасі можливо
Крим вже наш можливо кінець епохи
бідності це нам
обіцяли тому є певний Форпост і це наша
мова це те що показує що ми українці в
будь-якій країні світу тому Ми йдемо і
ми не будемо
зупинятись Ну і найголовніше ми
зібралися тут щоб бути разом І так вже
сталося що нас може меншість але нас уже
більша меншість ніж була але насправді
кожна людина яка тут присутня кожна
людина яка відстоює мову вона на вагу
золота тому прошу кожного Бережіть себе
бережіть ближнього носить маски мийте
руки не запалюйте фаєра тому що можливо
це зараз ні до чого але треба буде
приходити наприклад Завтра ми будемо
приходити тому що в цьому і є наше життя
не бійся
[музика]
житиль і коли залишилася зовсім сама І
коли вже здається світла нема коли небо
твоє на колір чужим стає
ти б виходила лінії знов на руціі
візнавала б надію в кожнім лиці малювала
в нослі Огонь і розбила б
скло не бійся жити світ для того щоб
любити сонце дощ і вітер либо свої квіти
нія тебе а ти не бійся жити сонце тошки
ітер небо твої крвіти світ для того щоб
любити
тебе Я сподіваюсь мене чути там в
Верховній Раді
ти йшла по межі ти йшов по межі тільки
знає Ніхто тобі не чужий і руха у руці
назавжди твоє
тепло і не можеш тепер лишитися там де
читаєш мої слова тогубав повертає тебе
назад моя
любов давайте разом не бійся жити світь
для того щоб любити Сонце тощ і вітер
немаввої квітрі Все для тебе а ти не
бійся жи ти сонце тошки вітер небо золі
квіти світ для того що ми любити
тебе а покажіть як нас багато
ти у серці своїм гамобаний стук ти на
дотик як спала навіть на звук Ти вже
майже Лети
відкрите вікно давно
розбивається ніч ламається час Тиха сила
вогонь не вгасне сча і не бійся любов
тепер береже
[музика]
тебе не бійся жити ввіля того щоб любити
сонце тожки вітер небо
й віти Все для тебе а Ти не бійся жити
сонце тошки вітер небо со і квіти світля
того щоб любити
тебе не бійся жити світля того щоб
любити Сонце дож і вітер небо солі квіти
це для тебе а ти не бійся жити сонце
тожні сіте небо з і іти Сіт для того щоб
любити
тебе світ для того
[музика]
щоб любити тебе
генда відля того щоб любити
тебе
Браво не бійся жити світ для того щоб
любити сонце дощ і вітер небо зорі квіти
Все для тебе а ти не бійся жити сонце
дощ і вітер небо зорі квіти світ для
того щоб любити
тебе борітися
поборимо Марічка
[оплески]
бормака якщо з українською мовою в тебе
друже не все
гаразд не вважай її примусовою Полюби як
весною рястд примусова вона тим хто
цурається А хто любить той легко вчить
все як пишеться в ній вимовляється все
як пісня у нійз звучить і журлива вона і
піднесена тільки фальш для неї чужа в
ній душа Шевченкова і Лесина і Франкова
у ній душа дорожи українською мовою
рідна мова основа
життя хіба мати бува
примусовою непутящем буває диття Ось
такі слова написали
написав свій час Дмитро білоуст А я хочу
запросити сюди на сцену
людину який був оточений повністю
московськомовним
середовищем якому нав'язували що
українське це не модно непристойне і
нікому не потрібне а він створював
український розмовний клуб у Донецьку
журналіст активіст переселенець із
Донецька якому ми маємо всі друж можна
помогти повернутися додому Сергій
стуканов Слава Україні
друзі
Слава сьогодні 30 років відколи було
проголошено Декларацію про державний
суверенітет На жаль тимчасово Мій рідний
край Донеччина і луганщина
є тими теренами на які суверенітет не
поширюється але це
тимчасово друзі Я 30 років мешкав на
Донбасі я мусив поїхати і сьогодні я
стою тут на цій сцені біля Верховної
Ради
чому друзі я звертаюся до вас я знаю що
серед вас є донечани луганчани
піднімайте руки Нехай всі знають що
донечани і луганчани сьогодні тут разом
З усією Україною тому що ми чи не
найкраще за всіх знаємо що таке
русифікація
русифікація - це підготовчий етап до
окупації тому
що дітям які говорять російською мовою
легше сказати Так ви йж насправді ближче
до Росії Ви росіяни а не українці які
розмовляють іншою
мовою тому русифікація - це перший етап
до того щоби забрати наші
домівки ви знаєте Я народився в Донецьку
я жив зростав в російськомовній родині
навчався в російськомовній школі але
згодом навчаючись на історичному
факультеті Донецького національного
університету який зараз гордо носить
ім'я Василя Стуса Мені відкрилася вся
істина про те що впродовж останніх
сторіч і
десятиріч мова використовувалася як
зброя проти України як зброя щоб
упокорити українців і тоді я свідомо
разом з однодумцями
однокурсниками переходив на українську
мову в Донецьку починаючи з 2004
року Спочатку це були малі середовища
але згодом вони
зростали Софія згадала про українські
розмовний клуб так це середовище яке
приваблювало донечан донечанок для того
щоб вони освоювали українську мову щоб
вони розуміли що українською можна
розмовляти повсякденно на будь-які теми
а не тільки заповнюючи довідку в якійсь
установі друзі Сьогодні ми
тут Тому що ми вибрали
майбутнє Ми хочемо майбутнього в якому
буде більше української мови більше ніж
мало наше покоління яке мусило справді в
російськомовному оточенні відстоювати
свої
права і хто як не Школа може створити це
середовище українські розмовні клуби
безкоштовні курси Це дуже добре але це
не той
рівень я можу навчати свою дитину вдома
української мови вставляти українською
мовою мультфільми на Ютубі Але коли вона
виходить на вулицю Коли вона приходить
до школи і потрапляє в російськомовне
середовище то українська сприйматиме це
як хатня мова але це не хадня мова
тому я сьогодні тут Щоби сказати панаму
у Верховній
Раді дайте можливість Донецьким і
луганським дітям нарешті опанувати
мову Яка буде провідником в український
світ а не в російський
світ
Ми не хочемо в минуле тому що в минулому
лише страх
приниження встидання своєї мови коли ти
мусиш озиратися
ні українська мова по повинна посісти в
Україні належне повноправне місце і в
тому числі ідному мені
Донбасі Донбас - це Україна і Донбас За
українську мову Донбас за мову Донбас за
мову Донбас за мову
Дякую І ось Сергій розповів свою історію
а я розповів кавалочок своєї Ну мені
пощастило народитися у Львові хоча мені
Схід і Захід разом я Тато з західної
України мама з Харківщини але українська
мова текла зразу в моїх жилах За що
дякую своїм батькам І ось говорячи своєю
рідною українською мовою зустрічаю
особливо зараз багато людей і з одного
боку кричать что я бандерівка нацистка
которыя не даёт людям говорить
по-человечески Ну не знаю як я це
заважаю бо по-людське це саме
українською а з іншого боку дуже багато
людей До мене підходить каже вы извините
Ну вот я не могу ещ на украинском Я
калечу язык Я не хочу калечить це той
варіант коли я відповідаю я вас
благаю
калічте
шпортайтеся забувайте слова
підшуковуйте говоріть 50 на50 але
говоріть
українською все решта я
допоможу Кожен з нас допоможе тому що ви
ніколи не навчитесь говорити українською
ви нівколи не навчитеся дихати і
відчувати українською якщо вона не буде
на устах А на устах Вона має бути від
першого кроку коли ти знаєш одне слово а
все решта не Українське в результаті
невдовзі стане той момент коли ти
повністю говоритимеш і думатимеш
українською так що не бійтеся
української мови говоріть вона заразна в
найкращому розумінні цього слова вона
найкраща і
наймилозвучніша і тепер маю приємність
запросити на цю сцену з одного боку
скажу теперішнього побратима бо разом
займаємося волонтерською діяльністю із
захистом України з іншого боку це
захисник якому я напевно так само як і
ви довіічно і доземно вдячна за захист а
з іншого боку це той українець який
московською мовою смалить москалів
ветеран московсько-української війни
волонтер і захисник Олексій
[оплески]
Петров
дкуємо
дякуємо
дякуємо Слава Украине героя Слава трудно
выступать после Генерала заброцского
потому что он каким-то образом читает
мысли но тем не менее я напомню ещё раз
Сегодня в июле 2020 года в центре Киева
столицы Украины Граждане Украины
вынуждены защищать государственный язиык
України українську мову датирували с
падлюки
я говорил говорю и буду говорить Нет
никаких слуг украинского народа есть
слуги Кремля иначе быть не может в 14м
году на нашу землю пришли российские
оккупанты я всю свою жизнь прожил в
Мелитополе Запорожской области да я ВС
жизнь говорил на русском языке я учился
в школе на русском языке И изучал
украинский язык Конечно я его Знаю и
когда мне говорят Я не понимаю что у вас
тут
написано я понимаю только одно Человек
лжёт и врёт и манипулирует все Граждане
Украины в школе в институтах в лицеи в
ПТУ изучали украинскую значит он
понимает о чём идёт речь когда враг
пришл на нашу землю они свято верили в
то что вот там на востоке и на
юго-востоке Украины живут русскоязычные
Граждане и они
постелят Красную
дорожку сраному русскому Миру и ядовитой
русской весне так они просчитали и они
пришли и что-то у них не
получилось просчитались опять потому что
70 а то и
80% личного состава батальонов и бригад
которые дислоцировались там на юге
юго-востоке Украины были русскоязычные и
взяли в руки оружие и пошли военкоматы
потому что сказали в гробу я видел таких
братьев которые приходят в мой дом с
оружием в грабу я видел такой братский
народ который приходит в мой дом с
оружием который хочет убить
меня мою семью моих родных и близких
даже тех кто сидели и ждали здесь
русский мир не верите спросите у тех кто
погиб поддами в Мариуполе 24 января 2015
года Почему мы так сделали ведь мы
вс-таки
русскоязычные Наши уже просчитали мы
должны были поселить Красную дорожку
потому что мы Граждане Украины а Святой
обовязок громадянина Украины захист
своеи
земли захист своеї
краины всей Украины понимаете всей ликом
это и мова это и вира это и армия это
Герб Прапор гим это даже та лавочка Где
в детстве сидел болтал Ногами и ел
немытую вишлю с дерева это вся Украина и
Украину мы будем защищать целиком чего
бы нам это не стоило и Украину сейчас
защищают целиком для того
чтобы слуги
Кремля ответили себе на вопрос ели в
Украине мовно пытание ущемляют ли здесь
украи русскоязычных или не ущемляют
нужно поехать на восток спуститься в
первый попавшийся блиндаж где-нибудь в
районе широкина либо авдеевки либо
желобка и посидеть там неделю просто
посидеть в уголке попить кофе послушать
ребят и сразу дойдёт мгновенно что нет
мовного пытания потому что там армия
потому что там
координаты братских оккупантов
передаются и российскою и украинскую и
на том языке который здесь упоминать
нельзя три слова сразу всё понятно где
находятся что с ними нужно делать и
ребята с ними
делают в
Украине Я надеюсь меня сейчас слышно там
в этом Верховной Раде в
Украине государственный язык державна
мова має бути тільки українська
українська ніяка инакше дома в баре на
рыбалке разговаривате хоть на китайском
Если вы его понимається ну освіта
українська на
100%
телебачення українською на 100%.
радіомовлення пісні українською на 100%
не не на 100 ACD се
оставим засоби масового зв'язку газети
журналиы и таке інше на 100% украинскою
повинобурки если кому-то хочется в этой
стране второй государственный язык
российский та какие проблемы такая
страна есть рядышком называется Россия
там государственнозык
российский чемоданы продаются в поезда
ходят пожалуйста везжайте наслаждайтесь
великим русским духом А здесь в
Украине державна мова повторяюсь будет
тільки українськую И если они этого не
понимают если они решили откусить
чуть-чуть они не атакуют мову напрямую
они попытались чуть-чуть откусить
немножко передвинуть границу в глуб
Украины л Зеленский в 14м году чуть-чуть
передвинуть откусить один кусочек второй
кусочек третий кусочек пятый 20тый в
конечном итоге не останется никакой
Украины будет здесь федеральный
приднепровский и
заднепровский округ России вернее не
будет его никогда здесь я вам
гарантирую Боевые повратимы сейчас
звонят с
фронта ребята с моего батальона звонят
говорят ко что там происходит если
сейчас передам все слова то меня выгонят
со
сцены Ну это как раз Вот тот армейский
язык на котором сразу всё стано понятно
они О
не а потом Даше ещё слово
твари потому что те парни которые стоят
сейчас Там на востоке которые держат
Мирное небо в том числе и для этих
засранцев они знают цену Миру они знают
Что такое Украина для них Украина вот
здесь в сердце вся Украина целиком как
мова так Віра так прапор гимн и таке
инше и я обращаюсь к слугам народа
Скажем так последнее китайское
предупреждение оставьте в покои державну
мову занимайтесь политикой занимайтесь
экономикой залишьте в покои державну
мову иначе если украинцы разозлятся вам
небо покажетсявн Слава
[оплески]
Украине
вінподобйре вміти московською мовою
засмалити всіх москалів і показати де
їхнє місце Ну а я маю велику приємність
вам ще трошки відзвітуватися Я знаю що
багато хто каже А ти до нас не
приїжджаєш а Ти нас ігнориш Ти маєш
працювати там там там тамта а тебе нема
А я знаю На кого це все зіпхати це все
Тернопільщина мене партія закріпила за
тернопільщиною тому мало того що саме
тернопільці розробили оцю бомбезну
рамочку захистити укра українську мову
так ще й Тернопільщина привезла сюди
рішення і заяви Тернопільської обласної
ради Я зараз запрошую сюди Тернопільську
команду європейської солідарності і
небайдужих людей на чолі з головою
Тернопільської обласної ради Віктором
[оплески]
овчаруком Слава Ісусу
Христу Слава
Україні ва Дорогі
українці Сьогодні ми тут разом з вами
представники найвищого представницького
органу Тернопільської області для того
щоб засвідчити свою повагу і
підтримати закон про українську державну
мову сьогодні тут також зі мною є і
представники депутатського корпусу
тернопської обласної
радиі ки фракцій це
керівник фракції Радикальної партії
Олега Ляшко Богдан
яциковський керівник
фракції Тернопільській обласній раді
європейської солідарності Степан
Барна секретар міської ради
Тернопільської на і Також недавно було
прийнято рішення
щодо унеможливлення
перегляду закону про українську державну
мову і Повірте що завтра тут буде
Більшість депутатів Тернопільської
обласної ради вони вже в
дорозі для того щоб
засвідчити те рішення яке ми розглядали
і підри римали Одноголосно 6
липня цього
року це
звернення Віктор
[оплески]
шумада Отже звернення депутатів
терномської обласної ради до президента
України Володимира Зеленського та голови
Верховної Ради України Дмитра разумкова
щодо спроб перегляду Закону України Про
забезпечення функціонування української
мови як державної і в тому числі і ще й
розгляду ційному суді Отже ми депутати
Тернопільської обласної ради глибоко
занепокоєні тим що в Україні
відбувається чергова спроба наступу на
українську мову вже 7 липня 2020 року
Конституційний суд України розпочне
розгляд внесеного народними депутатами
України подання щодо
відповідності Конституції України
конституційності Закону України Про
забезпечення функціонування української
мови як
державної боротьба реваншистів проти
закону про мову це не тільки намагання
нівелювання досягнення п'ятого
президента України Петра Порошенка це
прагнення путінських посіпак вислужиться
перед хазяїном
Кремля поки Влада зволікає з виконанням
ключових норм цього документу Та не
приймає закон про мови нацменшин
проросійські сили не зволікають вони
прикриваючись захистом прав
російськомовних громадян воюють з
українською мовою аби догодити Путіну
який вже давно мріє знищити нашу мову та
довести що ми один народ одночасно мовну
ситуацію роздмухують і тому що мова є
частиною захисту України у гібридній
війні з країномагресором Росією очевидно
що розмухують її ті хто хоче російського
реваншу на нашій території вимагаємо у
президента України Володимира
зеренського та голови Верховної Ради
України Дмитра разумкова жорсткої та
негайної реакції на такі ганебні спроби
нівелювати нашу українську мову як
державну ми попереджуємо що будь-які
намагання скасувати або внести зміни до
Закону України Про забезпечення
функціонування української мови як
державної отримують рішучу відсіч не
тільки від нас як депутатів рномської
обласної ради а від усіх патріотів
України принаідно хоче дкути всім хто
підтримує українську мову у такій
складній ситуації тому що Мова - це те
що визначає нашу самоідентифікацію
це те що найбільше хоче зруйнувати
агресор Але ми не дозволимо цього
зробити віримо в те що і Конституційний
суд України прийме виважене Рішення ще
особисто від себе Дорогі
українці чуть більше року коли був
прийнятий підтриманий закон про
українську мову як державну Здавалося
б збулася одвічна мрія українців
мільйонів українців тисячі українців які
віддали своє життя за боротьбу за
незалежну Українську державу в тому
числі і за мову але ж сьогодні очевидно
що Путін через своїх
агентів через народних депутатів слуг
народу хоче внести
зміни закон про українську
мову але ж тут сьогодні
звучало від народних депутатів про те що
ці слуги народу які внесли зміни до
закону які не розуміють української мови
вони ще й не знають історії
України тому що Протягом останнього
століття той же самий агресор Росії
проводила
русифікацію голодомором таборами
знищувала
українців І
сьогодні ми це
бачимо і сьогодні це завершилося тим що
агресор вступив на нашу
землю
Невже
сьогодні Наша сучасна Україна яка
заплатила гою ціною ціною крові і життів
Героїв Небесної Сотні добровольців
волонтерів і військових
українців які віддали своє життя за
Українську незалежну демократичну
державу в тому числі і за
мову тому що мова - це є душа
нації Тому що помові ідентифікують нас
Як
українців тому сьогодні замість того
щоб братися до наших національних
скарбів краще підніміть свою виборчу
[музика]
програму почитайте і ви здивуєтесь в неї
нічого не
виконано тому мова українська має
значення Слава Україні ро слава
Богдан
яцековський голова фракції Радикальної
партії Олега
Ляшка Слава Ісусу
Христу дорога
громада рік назад Ми пішли не тим шляхом
і знаєте за гарними фразами про нові
обличчя про нових
людей нам вдало маніпулятивно продали
кота в мішку
І за рік часу коли ми добре
придивилися то побачили що там
відніється солет двоголового
орла який піднімає крила і відкриває
клюв який нищить українську
економіку який наступає на українську
Віру на українські
цінності який як той злодій вночі продає
українську землю
і
сьогодні добирається до найсвятішого що
у нас є до
мови мова це є наш національний скарб
Цей фундамент національної ідентичності
за мову гинули і гинуть наші
патріоти ви знаєте я гордись того що
фракція Радикальної партії Олега Ляшка в
минулому скликанні Одноголосно
підтримувала закон про мову в Україні
має бути українська мова це те що нас
іня від інших народів це те що нас
робить сильнішими і те що нас робить
міцнішими ви знаєте коли важко українці
мають здатність завжди об'єднуватись так
було завжди і я бачу що зараз настає
саме той час коли ми маємо всі в
Незалежності від політичних поглядів Бо
Україна в нас одна мова в нас одна земля
в нас одна об'єднатися щоби дати відсіч
оцій Зеленій навалі яка сьогодні про про
наступає на Україну і я вважаю що
опозиційні сили мають сьогодні
об'єднатися і перший крок мають зробити
сьогодні в 208му виборчому окрузі
висунути єдиного кандидата від
опозиційних сил підтримати Ляшка бо його
потрібно в Верховній Раді підсилити
боротьбу проти зеленої чуми разом
об'єднатися на місцевих виборах піти і
виступити єдиним фронтом
знаєте поки ми є Поки лунає українська
мова поки ленає українська пісня
українське слово ми сильні і непоборні і
так буде завжди Україна була є і буде
Слава
Україні
Слава секретар тилобиської міської ради
Віктор
шумада дорога українська родино сьогодні
линуть до вас вітання з файного міста
Тернопіль І сьогодні тут в Києві
представлена наша потужна команда
європейської солідарності у
Тернопільській міській раді ще 29 травня
ми проголосували за звернення до цієї
зеленої влади а сьогодні наша команда
тут під Верховною Радою тому що ця Влада
діє як окупант а саме окупанти в Україні
нищили все українське окупанти в Україні
нищили носіїв української мови саме
окупанти 134 рази обмежували і
забороняли українську мову і сьогодні ми
тут щоб сказати цій Зеленій владі що
вони здійснюють політичну диверсію і
проти України і проти української нації
і проти всього українського тому ми
сьогодні кажемо цим зеленим шортякам
геть руки від солов'їної зелені чортяки
геть руки від солов'їної Слава Україні
Україна переможе Героям
слава голова фракції тенобській обласній
раді європейської солідарності Степан
Барна Слава Україні героя слава Слава
Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
Героям слава такими майданами ми
збиралися не один раз впродовж 400 років
українська мова переслідувалася
знищувалася і з нею боролися
51 указ
валуївській або подібний розпорядження
було спрямовано проти Української мови
чому Тому що Як казав той кого ми
ненавидимо Путін чтощо там где есть
русский язык там будет и Россия наше
завдання зробити все щоб на території
України було якомога менше російсько
мови не тільки тому що ми не любимо її
тому що ми виступаємо проти російського
імперіалізму який нав'язується нам з
Кремля підтримуємо це
так тому Тернопільська обласна рада
незалежно від партійної призалежності
займає Таку позицію Я вірю в тому що на
цьому майдані об'єднаються всі незалежно
від прапорів Чи це Конгрес українських
націоналістів чи свобода чи європейська
Солідарність чи Радикальна партія Олега
Ляшка ви всі єдині в одній спільній
справі боротьби проти Кремля і ми
переможемо правильно
так друзі Хотів би зазначити наступне що
останній закон який обмежував право
українців на спілкування рідною мовою
був прийнятий закон клічвчанхіва
в 2012 році і сьогодні ця влада яка
уособленням є не тільки зелені а є
уособленням інтересів Кремля через
агентів ФСБ в особі бужанського і
подібних представників слуг народу
нав'язує нам всій сценарій сценарій
інформаційної окупації нашої землі і
напевно не за це стоять наші хлопці на
сході нашої держави захищаючи українську
з землю вони стоять за того щоб ми мали
можливість відстояти власне право
розмовляти українською мовою і ми будемо
тут до кінця допоки українська мова не
переможе і ми маємо тут стояти сьогодні
завтра післязавтра і ми переможемо Слава
Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
Героям слава Слава Україні Героям
слава
Дякую от видите навіть тернопільським
нашим хлопцям сурми тут от заграли прямо
розпланували ідеально
але я би попросила зараз хто в тіньочку
попідтягатися
ближчіше тому що зараз вийде той щої хус
звучало а
вона вона сидітиме
сумна і зродились ми з великої години і
багато пісень які надихали ш боротьбу за
Україну легенда української пісні Тарас
[музика]
Чубай дай бо щастя
здоровля О я бачу трохи люди з лісу
виходять Я знаю що сонце
пече
люди виходьте з
[музика]
лісу я не буду говорити пафосних промов
я заспіваю пісню на вірші Богдана Ігора
Антоновича яка називається мова Гайова
можемо потренувати разом приспів який в
кінці буде там такі слова з всіх
найдивніша мова
Гайова всіх найдивніша
[музика]
Мова це те що вам треба співати зі мною
з всіх найдивніша мова
ва Росте Антонич і росте
[музика]
трава з всіх
найдівніша
мова Росте Антонич і росте трава
запам'ятали з всіх найдивніша мова
гогайова Давайте спробуємо репетиція
тчотири з всіх
найбівніша мовагайва
[оплески]
Росте Антонич і росте
трава тепер ви з всіх
найдивніша
[музика]
Пова Росте Антонич і росте трава і ще
раз всіх найдивніша
мова
і ще раз всіх найдивніша
мова і ще раз всіх
[музика]
найні Дякую Ви
чудові тепер граємо вцю
[музика]
пісню шгарадапарапада
шугарапарапапа Росте Антонич і росте
трава і зеленіють
кучеряві
вільки Ой нахилися нахилися
тільки почуєш найтай з всіх
[музика]
слова дощем квітневи весно не триво
хто стопнув звам страни блакитне небо
хто сип листякусні скла на
тебе
урешето ловити хочеш
дощ з всіх найдивніша
[музика]
мова рушницю ночі вклав хтось зорі кулі
на вільках місяць розплюють зозулі
[музика]
Росте Антонич і росте трава і тепер всі
разом з всіх найдивніша мова Гайова
Росте Антонич і росте
[музика]
трава всіх найдивніша
могава Росте Антонич і росте
могава всіх найде міця
мовагава ще раз всіх найдивніша мова
найва всіх найдивніша
полада з всіх найдивніш мова
жих найрівніша
мова найдивніша мова
росте антоміч і росте
[музика]
трава
на всі разом тричотири Гей
[музика]
[оплески]
на Я піду в далекі гори наш роки
полонини і попрошу втру звою аби ві не
спав до днини
щоблетів на вільних крилах на кічері і в
діброви діз нас Де моя мила
каріяч чорні брави всі разом Мила моя
друга боя звіта асм
звіт я я несу в очах до тебе весь
блакитний
світ я несу в любому
зажуру мрію
молоду і цвітуть шади для мене як до
тебе Ду
[музика]
я а як вітер з
полонини
прилетіти не захоче все одно знайду
дівчину чорні бви Хай очі перейду я
бистрі ріки і безкиди і діброги і шляхи
мені покажуть
карія чи чорні брови всі разом Мила моя
моя
я
зці я ришу
[музика]
бе я несу
ю
молоду і цвітуть сади для мене
якбитедидуйтевер щось не чувва
[музика]
[оплески]
і останній раз найголосніше
на
[оплески]
Дякую вам
Ленка за лентою
лента за лентою
Ленка вже вечір вечоріє повстанське
серце б'є А лента напої поспішно
подає наї
[музика]
юпа як сонце Сходило томлений юнак упав
він ранений упав він навзнак А хлента за
лентою набой подала український
постанчак в бою неступай А хлента ленкою
на
боїй український повстанче в боюни
ступає до нього санітар успішно іде в
обличчя вдивляєсь його впізнає А
хлентаю
[музика]
на Ах лента за лентою на бой подавай
український повстанче в бою не відступай
він в неї вдивляєсь пече в рулях рада
біля кулемета дівчина молода ахле тою
нава український поста ЧБ бою не
відступай
[музика]
ахлентаю а ворох атакує в останній
момент на ногу заграв вже затихлий
куленет Ах ленте тою набо подавай краі
Познань ахлента заленкою напої подавай
українській повстаньчи бою не відступай
ахлента
заленкою Слава
Україні
Слава Тарас чувай Дякую вам
[оплески]
дуже
б
Так виглядає що лента за лентою на бої і
не тільки на бої доведеться подавати ще
довго тому що пліснва вона не так легко
стирається але дуже швидко
розповсюджується так що для боротьби
треба Добрі багнети для боротьби треба
міцні стовпи і одним із стовпів
української державності особливо на
початку 90-х для нас став Конгрес
українських націоналістів сьогодні вони
з нами і Я запрошую до слова голову
конгресу українських націоналістів
Степана
браченя Слава Україні
Роя слава Слава українській нації
смеррова дорогі ми маємо достатньо жертв
для того щоб сьогодні на вже нарешті
говорити українською мовою і в побуті і
в державних установах ми
цього заслужили нам дав це право Господь
Бог дав право нам український народ який
відстоював в боротьбі це право я
пам'ятаю
славустицько коли вона також повернулася
в 91му році в Україну і
говорила Коли в Верховній Раді була
більшість червона червона Чума тоді
наповнювала її але українці 30 років
тому
зуміли протиснути і і все ж таки
прийняти держав державний акт про
суверенітет декларацію про суверенітет
України і ми знаємо що сьогодні
ми спадкоємці боротьби
Мазепи Богдана
Хмельницького Степана Бандери славних
Героїв УПА
маємо цей чин продовжити і наші багнети
можуть повернутися на тих ворогів які є
сьогодні і тут в Верховній раді ми їх
маємо про це попередити і сьогодні
справді підтверджую слова Мирослава Гая
який тут сказав Якщо хтось дозволить
спаплюжити нашу мову ми винесемо їх
ногами вперед
Сьогодні я як голова конгресу
українських націоналістів закликаю все
членство і всіх прихильників
мобілізуватися на захист України
української мови тому що це пробний
камінчик для повалення української
державності для наступу російської армії
це сьогодні
представники російської влади Росії
Кремля
розхитують наш човен думаючи що ми
приспані Ні ми не повинні бути приспані
тому що сьогодні Сергій фума співав
прокинься моя Україно і ми сьогодні ще
раз і ще раз говоримо прокинься моя
Україно за кого ти голосуєш за кого ти
вибираєш сьогодні виступав директор
директор інституту української мови
Павло Грицяк він сказав дуже хороші
слова Невже Ми українці не можемо мати
українську владу Невже Ми не можемо
обрати нашого президента українця Невже
Ми не можемо мати сьогодні свій уряд і
свій парламент тому ми говоримо
застереження цим хто сидить тут у у
цьому приміщенні у Верховній Раді але
багатьом це як горохом об стіну ми
говоримо також до всіх
українців усієї України думайте Ми не
можемо спаплюжити Сьогодні наш наше
завдання зберегти найсвятіше те що
ідентифікує це
мова тому якщо ми втратимо її Ми
втратимо дуже швидко територію нещодавно
на бережанщині помер один
із учасників боротьби у
нупа якраз один із в'язкових воєнної
округи лесоні я питав його
сина про що батько говорив останні
хвилини йому було би 99 років 92 роки
буквально вчора було девть днів по ньому
він мені сказав що батько журився про те
що антиукраїнські сили знову в наступі
що знову є загроза втратити мову друзі
Батько помер його з сумом і з тривогою
не Даймо нікому з наших батьків Помирати
сумом і тривогою ми маємо взяти Україну
українські руки і мати дійсно велику
Україну процвітаючу державу Слава вам
Слава Україні Слава українській
нації Слава
Що ж тут я маю такого хорошого
напаринька на сцені зараз заради таких
як він а його звати Сашко волков заради
таки як він Ми сьогодні відстоюмо
українську мову в школі заради таких як
він Ми сьогодні боремося за право бути
вільними українцями на своїй українській
землі Ну і Сашко має що
сказати я согодні буду розказувати вірш
Тараса Шевченка Думи мої думи мої думи
мої лихо мені з вами чому
лихо що стали на папері сумними рядками
Чому Чому вітер вас не розвіяв степу як
пилину чому лихо не приспало як свою
[оплески]
дитинулодело Сашко хоче говорити
українською мовою так що
молодець
молоти
молоди
молоти Ну але раз ми так почали з
найменшого покоління То тепер я запрошу
до слова покоління молоде але рівня моїх
студентів маю велику приємність за ось
цей от час нашої понадрічної особливо
боротьби зустрітися з молоддю з різних
регіонів України свідомою сильною які
знають що так в майбутньому стануть
політиками але вони хочуть бути
політиками нової якості якості такої яку
допоможе розбудувати українська
державність тому Я запрошую до слова
очільницю організації солідарна молодь
Дінара
хавівулаєва Слава
Україні
Слава скажу вам особисту історію Мої
батьки не українці і Народилась я в
Дніпрі ви скажете що Дінара взагалі має
спільно з українською мовою так але моя
сім'я виховала мене так аби я любила
країну де я живу поважала мову знала її
і розуміла культуру сталося так що
українська мова стала для мене
рідною
[оплески]
але зараз відбувається Так що Зелена
Влада робить все аби майбутнє
покоління молоді
політиків професіоналів були
русифіковані вони зараз наступають не
тільки на мову вони наступають на
культуру на нашу
історію на освіту вони наступають на нас
на
українців молодь ви пам'ятаєте всі в
2013 році Перша вийшла аби боротися за
європейське майбутнє а зараз Зелена
Влада змушує молодь виходити ще раз або
боротися за українське майбутнє Чи це є
справедливість чи це є за то до чого ми
йшли давайте крикнемо всі ганьба ганьба
ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба українська мова - це Код нації і
зелена Влада зараз намагається його
розірвати але українська нація сильна
незалежна вольова Цього ніколи
не дасть тому що ми одна єдина Соборна
Україна одна єдина свободна Україна одна
єдина свободна Україна одна єдина
Соборна Україна одна єдина Соборна
Україна одна
єдинами
сильні солідарні Слава Україні гро Слава
ра
Нара
[музика]
Нара А зараз вийде людина котра точно
розкаже як жити в маленькому містечку
голова Вінницького обласного осередку
солідарної молоді Богдан
Арсенюк вітаю я з маленького міста як і
сказала Дінара на
Вінниччині мову повчав вивчати спочатку
Майдану і коли я
розмовляв рідною мовою В мене запитували
А ви звідки з західної України Я кажу ні
я з Вінниччини з центральної і я тоді
подумав про те чому українці хто
спілкується українською мовою це це ті
хто живуть на заході українська мова є
по всій Україні українською спілкуються
по всій Україні в багатьох містах я хочу
сказати про те що українська мова є
невід'ємною частиною це те що нас
відрізняє від інших націй і ми повинні
її берегти Ми живемо в
Україні ми спілкуємось українською і ми
солідарна молодь будемо захищати
українську мову ми будемо її захищати
тут Тому що іншої мови у нас немає і
українська мова вона найгарніша найкраща
і
наймалозвучніша тому мова понад
ус сильні по
солідарні
і так скромно пішов Ні це неправильно ми
дійсно сильні бо ми солідарні тому
Скажемо разом сильні бо солідарні сильні
бо солідарні сильні бо солідарні сильні
бо солідарні і тому вони нас там так
бояться Ну а щоби їм стало ще страшніше
щоб призгадці при будь-якому порушенні
прав української мови їм там гикалося
вздовж і в поберег я сьогодні хочу
запросити абсолютно неймовірних людей
які з різних регіонів України але
представляють нашу команду європейської
солідарності і справи громад петрошкутяк
івано-франківськ Марина соломко-
Дніпро Олена борейко- Одеса Оксана
погомій - Херсон Сергій Довжанський
Чернівці Сергій корінний - харківщина
Дмитро кошка- Дніпро
[музика]
Слава
україніва до 14-го року я розмовляла
російською потім я почала писати
українською потім Я перейшла на суржик І
зараз я намагаюся гарно правда не завжди
це в мене виходить але розмовляти тільки
українською Чому Тому що война Не
закінчиласяйна
вона проходить не тільки там на фронті
на сході не тільки в Криму за наш Крим
Вона проходить І в наших Головах і коли
ми будемо чітко розуміти що наша мова -
це наш код нації тоді ми переможемо і
хай буде Україна всюди Слава
нації Слава Україні
Сергій сьогодні в Україні Є всі ознаки
проросійського
наступ на мову наступ на церкву
політичні переслідування опозиції
переслідування волонтерів медиків
військових це все що сьогодні уособлюєця
ганебна Зелена влада в Україні
законопроект
2362 спрямований на знищення
самоідентичності українців на знищення
Української держави як було вже тут
зазначено попереду місцеві вибори хочу
закликати всіх об'єднатися
і виступити єдиною колоною на виборах
тоді ми можемо скласти точно реальну
альтернативу чимцим зеленим недологам та
відвертим колабораціоністам які тільки
мріють про Реванш п'ятої колони для того
щоб завести троянського коня Путіна в
Україну Мова - це генетичний код нації
Слава Україні Слава кожному з нас
об'єднуємося і перемагаємо Слава Україні
Героям слава
Слава Ісусу
Христу Слава Україні
Слава Я сьогодні тут з Одещини щоб
сказати тим неукам які випадково
потрапили до нашого парламенту що ми за
єдину державну мову за
Українську іншого питання не може стояти
Я сьогодні дуже вдячна за те що я з вами
я Вдячна Богу що я маю честь
представляти сьогодні одещину отут перед
вами ми сильна на
Ми багато
тисячоліть нас знищували а Ми стояли ми
збудували свою країну свою незалежну
Україну нас ще є багато роботи і я думаю
що ми переможемо Я впевнена що ми
переможемо
ми Шляхетна нація ми попри всі
випробування ми зберегли примножили наші
традиції нашу культуру нашу мову але ми
дуже толерантна нація багато тисяч літь
ми терпіли тих кака кого Какая
разница для нас особисто для
Балти точкою такою неповернення став
14-й рік коли Ми зрозуміли що зброя - це
не тільки гармати зброя - це мова зброя
- це віра тому ми спільними зусиллями
збудували свою церкву спільними
зусиллями ми проводимо багато різних
заходів для наших дітей бо діти
визначають наше майбутнє
саме тому сьогодні Агенти тої сторони
порушують це питання і недаремно це не
перед виборами Бо саме вони роблять
ставку на дітей саме діти формують націю
України Я дуже вдячна всім Що ви
сьогодні
тут плекаємо нашу мову збагачуємо її а
тим кому не подобається наша мова хто не
хоче її шанувати я можу порадити знаєте
що значає коли жінка робить отак геть з
України Москва вокзалшков бо Ростов це
занадто розкішно для них Ростов - це теж
Україна Слава нація Слава українській
мові українська мова пережила на одну
наругу пам'ятаємо історію тільки
російський чобіт став на землю України в
часі бодана Хмельницького перше що вони
робили - це нищили нашу віру і нашу мову
і їм тоді виявлялося не все
равно потім царський Влада так само
придумувала палуївські циркуляри емські
циркуляри та інші напрямки щоби зничити
українську мову щоб взагалі її не було
як вони казали А такої вообще не
существуют але все одно вона вистояла
потім червоні Кати теж поставили питання
що українська мова - це є те на чому
будується українська нація на чому люди
збираються об'єднуються і бореться проти
окупантів і саме тому це є саме страшне
для всіх окупантів які є і саме страшне
для російських окупантів для окупантів у
вигляді бужанського опзж всяких шуфричів
і іншої наволочі Яке приходить на нашу
землю ми маємо їх принижати ногтем до
землі бо тому що якщо ми зараз не
Захистимо українську мову ми втратимо
державу
2 рік коли Ківалов і всяка інша Партія
регіонів пробували знищити українську
мову і тут мені згадується як деякі
навіть проукраїнські люди казали ну може
так і треба це робити мені згадуються
наші буковинці які в часи радянської
окупації таки як Івасюк як Назарій
Яремчук Павло Дворський співали
українською мовою і не лягали під цю
російську окупаці
ідеологію і саме на них треба опиратися
і саме в той час коли це все проводилося
тому пам'ятаємо це боремся відстоїмо
українську мову і ще одне таке виникає
питання а де наш президент президент
України його фракція член його
фракції подає такий законопроект де його
думка Він підтримує
його якщо він підтримує таку думку тоді
він не президент України він президент
Малоросії і президент окупованих
територій і тому як український народ
Мар сказати йому геть від нас геть з
цієї території і хай йде до свого пана
пана Путіна і хай з ним і живе тому ми
не дозволимо цього зробити ми будемо
боротися і тому Україна понад усе Слава
Україні Героям слава целюгей целюгей
целюгей целюгей целюгей е елю гень елю
гень елю гень елю гень елю гень елю
геньгегеге Бажаю здоров'я вітання Вам з
дніпропетровщинивава
ми тут для того щоб показати що Дніпро
може народжувати не тільки всяких там
божанських А іще має щоденно зростаючу
україномов
спільноту я пам'ятаю коли після АТО
приїхав в Київ в 15-му році і тут мене
зустріла повністю україномовне таке
місто бо моя сім'я тут сім'я сестри
розмовляли виключно української мови
Коли я приїхав в 18-му році вони вже
розмовляли російською і знаєте чому так
трапилось тому що їх дитина ходила в
україномовну початкову школу з 15 по 17
рік а потім перейшла в російськомовну
середню і вони перейшли на російську
мову саме це і хоче зробити зараз пан
бужанський мені подарували оцю футболку
тут на спині написано Повірте наслово
повернутись не
можу написано подякую вчителю за те що
можеш це прочитати і подякуй
ветерану за те що читаєш це українською
ість років хлопці на фронті боронять
нашу країну від руского мира і явно вони
роблять це не для того щоб зараз їм в
спину вструмили ніж оцим от законом
новим мовним законом тож ми маємо
захистити ми маємо підтримати наших
воїнів бо без мови немає нації Слава
нації с ва і слава Україні героям
слава
Слава
українілава друзі Мені сказали говорити
стисло я багато чого хотіла сказати але
я зупинюсь на таких речах для мене дуже
приємно сьогодні бути тут і для мене
дуже важливо сьогодні бути тут ми
приїхали з Дніпра з нашою командою
європейської
солідарності для тощо сказати що Дніпро
буде протистояти будь-яким потуранням
московським забаганкам ми проти того
щоб Зелена влада намагалася знищити
українську ідентичність і українську
державність для мене дуже символічно
також що сьогодні на цій сцені грав
Тарас
Чубай тому що його пісні Стали для мене
початком захоплення і любові до
української мови
я навчалася в російсько мовній школі і
коли її закінчила пішла на факультет
української філології і коли я слухала
пісні пана Тараса щоб ви розуміли як
російськомовна освіта впливала впливає і
впливатиме на людей я спершу думала що
слово спроквола яка є в його піснях це
якась
істота Тобто я не розуміла що це слово
означає і коли я поїхала до Львова
вперше в 2006 році і потрапила в суто
україномовне середовище для мене це було
настільки вражаюче настільки захопливо
що з того часу я постійно розмовляю
українською мовою в побуті і всюди тобто
в Дніпрі я постійно розмовляю
українською мовою і коли в мене
запитують коли мене запитують як почати
говорити українською як навчитися
говорити
українською Моя порада одна просто
говоріть Дякую і Слава Україні Героям
слава Слава Україні Героям слава митро
шкутяк
івано-франківськ Я тільки декілька слів
в 2012 році Коли прийняли закон кивалого
колесниченка ми оголосили голодування на
сходах украї
дому один з
голодувальників хлопців там були двоє
хлопців на початку і троє дівчат Це був
Сашко Капінос Сашко Капінос з
Тернопільщини загинув 18 лютого 2014
року в боях на
Майдані Я пішов на війну і був поранений
на війні після нас питалося чого ви
голодуєте Тобто що це дасть ми
казали в Україні на зріває велика
проблема знищенням мови знищують державу
голодуємо ми не через то що ми слабкі не
через то що Ну безвихідь а через то що
Ми змушені своїм голодуванням привернути
увагу суспільства до дуже важливої
проблеми і питання які вносить закон
Ківалова колесниченка в Україну але
Україна почала боротися відбувся Майдан
після Майдану Росія вже вводила війська
окуповувала Крим вводила війська на
Донбас Ми ми створили армію і воювали на
Донбасі ми відвоювали 2/3 Донбасу ми
пролили кров і держава в цей час коли
відбувалась війна розвивалася держава
була прийнята
декомунізація була створена українська
армія нова українська армія не тільки за
формою за новою зброєю за оснащенням але
і за суттю своєю внутрішньою армія стала
українською і в 2019 році був при
прийнятий надзвичайно важливий закон про
мову який
підписав голова тодішньої Верховної Ради
Андрій Парубій і п'ятий президент
України Петро
Порошенко але сьогодні обманом обманом
людей і обливанням бруду українських
політиків бруду українських політиків
українських лідерів прийшли до влади в
Україні слуги Кремля це опзж І це так
звані зелені слуги народу і вони
виконують знову всі вказівки Кремля по
знищенню фундаменту Української держави
української
культури української традицій і
української і основне це української
мови ми не будемо вже голодувати ми дамо
їм бій Ми дамо їм бій і будемо давати
бій тут всередині в Україні так як наші
війська тримають і дають бій на сході
України і для того щоб дати цей бій нам
потрібно об'єднатися всім патріотичним
силам в Україні сьогодні потрібно
об'єднатися і перемагати і нам потрібен
командир так як і в бою на війні Нам
потрібен завжди був бо мудрий командир
так і тут в внутрішній нашій політичній
боротьбі Нам потрібен
мудрий досвідчений командир і таким
командиром є Петро Порошенко який В
своїй діяльності і своєї боротьби
доказав своєю життєво своїм життєвим
шляхом що він вміє досягати результату
заради інтереси інтересу держави Україна
він доказав свою відда
Українській державі дуже багато дуже
часто ми на жаль не можемо ми
захищаємо українських лідерів ми часто
захищаємо поетів ми
захищаємо скажемо так громадських діячів
дуже часто ми ще й захищаємо їх
посмертно але нам потрібно навчитися
захищати і українських політиків і
державотворців сьогодення які роблять
важливі справи для того щоб існувала
держава Україна і сьогодні нам ми змогли
на цих судах які ми їздили поспіль
Щотижня ми захистили п'ятого президента
України Петра Порошенка і сьогодні
давайте
ми знайдемо і він буде цим командиром
який об'єднає навколо себе патріотичні
сили щоб ми дали бій і перемогли заради
того щоб українська держава відбулася
Дякую Слава Вам слава Україні Героям
слава Дякую усім нашій команді і на жаль
цей бій буває занадто болючим Я хочу щоб
ми сердечно привітали мати справжнього
героя України який зараз нас захищає з
небес бійця командира бійця батальйону
Айдар Олексія сапожнікова пані Світлана
Світлана сапожнікова
прошу
Слава Україні
ро
Слава
я мама
солдата бійця захисника патріота
добровольця який як і тисячу десятки
тисяч наших українських чоловіків стали
на захист своєї держави України та на
жаль
залишилися на полі
бою в мого Олексія було все для
щасливого життя дім
робота
сім'я А ще в нього було і я цим дуже
горжуся
гідність Чуєш бужанський
гідність про яку ви не
знаєте
дуже
боляче Душа болить серце зранене
коли відбувся цей Реванш зараз десь в ці
хвилини іде суд над волонтерами
переслід ветеранами волонтерами
переслідуються
так не має
бути вже в незаконі
томос армія вже не та що
була і взялися за
мову а Мова це наша
броня буде жива мова буде наша
держава Дякую вам усім Я вас всіх дуже
люблю Я вже
повідомила на
рівненщину що тут всі
свої Слава Україні Героям
слава
дякуємо
дякуємо дякуємо
дякуємо Його пісні є символом України
справжні давні І незнищениї сьогодні він
тут з нами і теж нам заспіває заклик до
боротьби А я з його пісень напевно
найбільшіше люблю йде січове вісько тай
співає
стиха як поборем
воріженьків небу не нам
лиха Тарас
Компаніченко та товариство Доброго дня
Слава Україні Героям слава е дивно що і
досі триває боротьба за Українську мову
і досі триває боротьба яку ми ведемо
більше 30 років зрештою ця Боротьба не
спинялася протягом боротьби
шістидесятників власне боротьба в 70-х
роках української гельзнської групи була
так само за проти утисків За українську
мову проти утисків Української мови
боротьба яку вів Дзюба Іван написавши
дуже дуже марксистський твір
інтернаціоналізм чи росифікація це
боротьба за Українську мову колись
теперішні адепти і слуги
Москви в і в одній і іншій фракції Я маю
на увазі опзж і в слугах народу говорять
що українська мова українській мові було
комфортно в Радянському Союзі
українській мові було добре бо бачите
була третина на телебаченні тільки
справді ніхто на Хрещатику не говорив
окремі адепти української мову ми ми
були свідками того коли українська
хороша
література не вивчалася
українська інтелектуальна література не
вивчалася література яка чи українська
культура не була
актуальною дуже гарно щоб ми всі носимо
віночки барвіночки Я теж це дуже люблю і
займаюся дуже старовинною українською
культурою середньовіччям ренесансом
барокко який тися років і так далі
але зробити просто ерзац коли українська
культура є на показ така така собі як
культура аборигенів а все актуальне все
сучасне все те що хвилює сучасну людину
буде по московськи це шлях в гетто і
шлях в те що українці не будуть хотіти
бути українцями Молодь не хоче бути
українцем не хотіла бути українцем оці
всі абсурдні моменти з з шкільництвом ми
зараз спостерігаємо оці всі
облуди що давайте ще відкладемо давайте
ще відкладемо дуже просто дуже просто
друзі Ми виховуємо дітей які мають здати
ЗНО просто дуже в Україні аби працювати
це вони отримують безкоштовне навчання в
Україні ці діти ми отрима Це безкоштовне
начення з наших податків в майбутньому
Ці діти Ми сподіваємося що будуть
працювати в Україні щоб платити податки
і утримувати нас пенсіонерів а не для
того щоб вони вивчаться тут в Україні не
будуть знати української мови і
вступлять в московські ВУЗи угорські
ВУЗи чи ще кудись це дуже делікатний наш
закон який ми зробили минулого року він
україноцентричний він передбачає і
забезпечення прав на національних меншин
і їхнє святе право але він робить
українців різних національностей
українцями в Україні
Василь
[музика]
Стус
за читанням
[музика]
яснарікавабати
розпросторся душе
моя на
чотири
татамі
і не
кулься
одная і не
крийся
руками хай У
тебе є дві вежі та
середина
справжня
марневороже
ворожить
молода
чи
[музика]
поважна
посередині
стовбурліть а оба боки
крона
посередині вічний Слід Від
колиски до
скону жальні
неба Тані землі в цій
труні
вертикальні і
[музика]
заврунилися жалі
думи
всілись
печальні
як то
синиця мені
земля на
якій лишно
чую як
мені небеса
болять коли їх
Я не
чую раз
постав у в очах мій край каже
стов
осіянний каже сна
рикарай він для
мене кохали
[музика]
ж просто ся душе
моя на
чотири
татамі і не
кулься одна я і не
крися
[музика]
руками
Дякую Ну і пісня української революції
на слова Бориса
Гринченка рідний стяг або стяг це твір з
збірки збірка пісні про
визволення Борис Гринченко засновник
Просвіти на на дніпрянщині великий
письменник перекладач поет його твори
дуже багато озвучували цей твір
озвучував Феодосій часник з сячеслава з
Дніпра тепер ми не не знаємо такого
композитора Ярослав ярославенко написав
Прекрасну мелодію В 19-му році і ось це
але водночас цей твір співали на народні
мелодії і на на на ой не ходигрицю та й
на вечорницю так само як Ще не вмерла
Україна До речі попробуйте Ще не вмерла
Україна дуже гарно підходить на Ой не
ходи грицію тай на вечеірниці е Отже в
19-му році козак Запорозької групи Борис
Антоненко Давидович
згодом видатний письменник розстріляного
відродження іде в атаку проти денікінців
під оратовим на Вінниччині і каже що ж
мені співати аби підтримати своїх
козаків які занепали духом і каже Ой на
горі та жнці жуть дезертири бруть бо
вони там переробляли пісню про Дорошенка
сагдачно і починає співати стяг і каже
не знаю чи слухали минедавня далека Лава
але ближні козаки підхопили і ось
лунає широко наше Слава по всій по
всьому байраку по всій по всій долині а
денікінці злякалися кричати уря а ми
ідемо ідем над нами майрить наш
національний стяг і ми співаємо наш
рідний стяг
[музика]
Ось він
високо над нами стяг
Освячений в боях гей хто з нами не з
рабами хто стоптав ганебний страх
станьмо в кубі за Україну
бимосьбиймо з до загинув станьмо в купі
за Україну биймось биймось до загин
глянь
написано на ньому
ля сонце волі нам поля
духови людському і
робітницьким
рукамрнем волю на Україну биймось
биймось до загину вернем во
на Україну биймось биймось до загин Ось
Він кличе Ось він має станьмо всі ми
навкроги
Грім і пекло не злякає Згинуть наші
вороги гей застяг наш до загину биймось
биймось за Вкраїну гей за стяг наш до
загину биймось биймось за країн Ось він
високо над нами стяг
скриваволений в боях гей хто з нами не з
рабами хто здолав ганебний страх станьмо
в купі й до загину биймось биймось за
країну станьмо вку
й до загину биймось биймось за україн і
тотож за стяг наш то загину биймось
биймось за країну Тож застяг наш хто
загину биймось биймось за
країну і разом з вами і і і хтож застяг
наш хто загинув
бимось биймось за
Вкраїну Тож застяг наш то загинув
биймось биймось за країн Тож застяг наш
до за віну биймось биймось за Вкраїну
Тож засяяг наш до загину биймось биймось
за країну Слава Україні Героям
слава Тарас
Компаніченко шановні друзі Сьогодні
справді Великий день Сьогодні 16 липня
це день коли ми відзначаємо 30цтиліття
проголошення декларації про незалежність
яка стала одним з найважливіших напевно
в історії України XX століття кроку до
повної незалежності Сьогодні 16 липня і
це день коли ми відзначаємо першу
річницю вступу в дію закону про мову і
ми разом з вами тут стоячи на цій акції
стоячи на цьому протесті не дозволили
зробити так щоб 16 липня було
заплямовано ухваленням антимовного
закону бужанського Сьогодні його вже не
буде ухвалено це наша
перемога але в нас залишається один день
один день коли цей закон може бути
ухвале це завтра чому так поспішають
тому що якщо цей закон буде ухвалено
завтра то перехід російськомовних шкіл
на українську мову який має відбутися 1
верезня цього 2020 року може бути
зупинений може бути відкладений через це
не маємо права розхолоджуватись через це
закликаю всіх прийти завтра сюди Ми
будемо продовжувати нашу акцію Завтра ми
оголошимо пікет для того аби зупинити
можливість ухвалення закону бужанського
завтра тут о
нам треба простояти ще один дуже
важливий день Якщо це не буде завтра ми
переможемо остаточно Дозволь я тільки ще
додам до цих слів що завтра тут під
стінами Верховної Ради має відбутися
виїзна сесія Львівської обласної ради на
підтримку української
мови шановні друзі великий Дякую кожному
хто простояв тут насправді ви зробили
дуже велику справу зробили цю справу
якою будуть гордитися і наші нащадки ми
дозволяємо повернутися русифікації в
українські школи це надзвичайно важливо
через це і дуже прошу вас мобілізуватися
завтра 9:30 тут же під Верховною Радою
Приходьте будь ласка приводьте своїх
друзів разом переможемо
що ж і до підсумовуючого слова запрошую
Андрія
парубія Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
героям слава я перш за все хочу
подякувати всім тим хто сьогодні приїхав
на майдан біля Верховної Ради України з
усіх куточків України від Харкова Одеси
до Волині і Закарпаття вас була багато в
кого недоспана ніч бо ви їхали захищати
мову в Київ і тут під палючою спекою Ви
стояли цілий деньро Міли позиція кожного
з вас має величезне значення позиція
кожного має значення ми усвідомлюємо Нам
доводиться щоденно захищати наші базові
цінності і мову і армію і віру і Україну
і кожен з вас сьогодні дав звіт і
продемонстрував свою готовність і
здатність захищати Україну І зараз ми
можемо твердо сказати закону вже не буде
на розгляді 15 година сесія зараз
завершиться і я вітаю кожного з вас з
цією надважливою
перемогою для них це був ключовий день
невипадково і голова фракції слуг народу
і розумков в понеділок повідомили що ми
в четверг будемо розглядати бо найвища
мобілізація найбільша кількість
депутатів є весь час в четвер але ми
змогли домогтись того
що сьогодні вони не посміли наголошую не
не захотіли а не посміли поставити закон
бужанського на розгляд і це заслуга
кожного з вас Дякую усім Вітаю вас
аплодую
вам бо нам було легше в сіному залі Вам
тут на палючому сонці було важче і Хочу
наголосити завтра ще є ризик ризик
залишається якщо ми сьогодні робили
велике вічя то завтра я хочу підтвердити
тут буде Львівська обласна рада і будуть
депутати і інших град і тому я прошу
киян киян хто буде завтра пікет тут під
стінами Верховної Ради ми маємо бути
насторожі 9:30 ми проводимо пікет щоб
бути на сторожі ми будемо всередині щоб
за будь-яких обставин завтра не
дозволити І не дати перейти до розгляду
цього закону після того сесія
закривається і це буде наш вирішальний
бі бій і гарантія того що з 1 вересня
всі діти в Україні будуть мати змогу і
право в Україні вивчати українську мову
і це заслуга усіх нас бо де українська
мова там перемога бо де українська мова
там Україна бо мова єднає бо Мова - це
наша зброя Дякую усіх з перемогою Слава
Україні героя слава
Героям слава Слава Україні Героям слава
Дякуємо Андрію паробію хочу сказати ще
одну важливу річ через годину в стінах
цього парламенту відбудеться урочиста
сесія присвячена якраз 30ритиріття
ухвалення декларацію про суверенітет
учасниками цієї сесії зокрема будуть
батькизасновники Незалежності депутати
цього першого скликання 1990 року які
голосували за декларацію які голосували
за Акт проголошення незалежності 24
серпня 91го року завдяки вам всім нам
всім не буде соромно дивитися їм в очі
ми будемо дивитися їм в очі і будемо їх
вітати сьогоднішнім святом а не будемо
біткатися що сьогоднішній день став днем
коли почалася Реванш русифікації Дякую
всім ми разом перемагаємо і за нашою
традицією наш захід ми завершуємо
національним гімном України і запрошую
знову побратима Тараса компаніченка
[музика]
Ще не
вмерла
України ні слава ні
Боля ще нам браття
українці
усміхнеться
доля згинуть на наші
боріженьки як роса на
сонці
забануєміми браття у свої
сторонці Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І пока кажем що ми браття
козацького
родуду Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І покажем що ми браття
козацького роду
стане братя в бі Кривавий
відсяянув
додолу віднім краю
панувати не дамо нікому
Чорне море ще сміхнеться ді Дніпро
зрадіє
ще у нашій Україні
Ленька
досіє Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободуду і покажем що ми браття
козацького
роду душу й тіло ми
положим за на нашу
свободу І покажем що ми браття
козацького
роду а завзяття
прая щира щого ще
докаже щестя волі в
Україні піснь гучна
розля же
закарпати
відіб'ється
звомони
степами
України слава стане поміж
наротами Душу й тілом ми
положим за нашу
свободу І покажем що ми браття
козацького родуду
душуй тілом ми
положим за нашу
свободуду і покажем що ми браття
козацького
роду Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
нації Смерть ворога Україна понад
усе Отож До зустрічі завтра 9:30 тут так
так чекаємо
переможемо